Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions an average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放，因此六家最大的公司携手合作，在通往净零排放的道路上取得进展。他们投资于技术和创新，使每桶石油的平均碳排放量已经减少了 22%。他们与政府合作以创造和保护就业机会，并正在开发世界上最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，并且我们正在多条路径上取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Music Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode contains violence against children that won't be suitable for all listeners. In October 1955, Grant Beaumont, better known to friends as Jim, entered a city hotel in Adelaide on a high after a win at the horse races. The Australian Army veteran had recently returned to South Australia after years spent serving overseas
音乐 我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集包含不适合所有听众的针对儿童的暴力内容。1955 年 10 月，朋友们更熟悉他叫吉姆的格兰特·博蒙特在赛马场赢得大奖后情绪高涨，走进了阿德莱德的一家城市酒店。这位澳大利亚陆军退伍军人最近刚从海外服役多年回到南澳大利亚，
and was now working as a taxi driver for local cab company Suburban Taxis. He owned several vehicles, working hard long hours to earn extra income. Keen to celebrate his win at the races with a drink, Jim walked into the Victoria Hotel on Heintaly Street in the heart of Adelaide City. His attention was immediately drawn to a woman who was sitting eating a meal with another couple. Struck by her natural beauty and warm brown eyes, Jim worked up the courage to approach the woman who introduced herself as Nancy Ellis. The two hit it off immediately. Just six weeks after their first date, Jim proposed to Nancy and by December that year, the pair were married. Nine months later, in September 1956, they gave birth to their first child, a daughter they named Jane Natter. November 1958 marked the arrival of Anna Kathleen, the Beaumont's second daughter.
现在正为当地的出租车公司“郊区出租车”担任出租车司机。他拥有几辆汽车，辛勤工作很长时间以赚取额外收入。吉姆渴望喝一杯来庆祝他在赛马场上的胜利，于是走进了位于阿德莱德市中心的亨特利街的维多利亚酒店。他的注意力立刻被一位正与另一对夫妇坐在一起用餐的女士吸引了。吉姆被她天生丽质和温暖的棕色眼睛所打动，鼓起勇气走近这位自我介绍叫南希·埃利斯的女士。两人一拍即合。在第一次约会的仅仅六周后，吉姆就向南希求婚了，到了那年 12 月，两人就结为了夫妻。九个月后，即 1956 年 9 月，他们迎来了第一个孩子，一个被他们命名为简·娜特的女儿。1958 年 11 月，博蒙特的第二个女儿安娜·凯瑟琳出生了。
By July 1961, their idyllic family was complete upon the arrival of a third and final child, a boy named after his father, Grant Ellis. The Beaumonts were the quintessential Lossy family. By 1966, 41-year-old Jim Beaumont had traded driving taxis for a new career in sales. He worked as a traveling salesman for a linen company, while his wife, 39-year-old Nancy, stayed home to take care of their three young children. Nine-year-old Jane Beaumont was wise beyond her years. Incredibly well-spoken and intelligent, Jane was a shy girl who enjoyed reading, writing, poetry, and playing outdoors. She had a love for academia that encouraged a dream of becoming an author or teacher when she grew up. Her polished composure would crack when excited, causing her speech to delightfully stutter. As the oldest of the three Beaumont children, Jane exuded a level of maturity and protectiveness that her parents likened to a 15-year-old.
到 1961 年 7 月，随着第三个也是最后一个孩子的降生，一个男孩以他的父亲格兰特·埃利斯的名字命名，他们田园诗般的家庭终于圆满。博蒙特一家是典型的洛西家庭。到 1966 年，41 岁的吉姆·博蒙特已经放弃了开出租车，转而在销售领域开启了新职业。他是一家亚麻公司的旅行推销员，而他 39 岁的妻子南希则呆在家里照顾三个年幼的孩子。9 岁的简·博蒙特成熟得超乎年龄。简能言善辩且聪明过人，是一个喜欢阅读、写作、诗歌和在户外玩耍的害羞女孩。她对学术的热爱促使她产生了长大后成为一名作家或教师的梦想。她优雅沉着的仪态在兴奋时会打破，导致她说话时会发出令人愉快的口吃。作为三个博蒙特孩子中的老大，简流露出一种让父母比作 15 岁少年的成熟感和保护欲。
Jane embraced her natural maternal qualities by watching protectively over her two younger siblings. Seven-year-old Anna Beaumont was the more extroverted of her siblings, with a wild imagination that could keep her entertained for hours. Outgoing and affectionate, Anna loved seeing, dancing, playing dress-ups, and putting together concerts that she would perform in front of her family, sometimes roping her brother and sister in on the act. The baby of the family, four-year-old Grant Beaumont Jr. was a little gentleman who vitalised his father. He'd shadow-gim around the house, watching as his father completed domestic tasks and pretending to be his little assistant. In another attempt to be just like his dad, Grant would zip around in a red go-kart, acting as though it was a taxi. Grant was a sweet and friendly little boy, and the family doted on him lovingly. Jim Beaumont's job as a travelling salesman meant he often had to spend days at a time on the road, and while he disliked being away from his family, it afforded them a modest, comfortable lifestyle.
简欣然接受了她天生的母性品质，保护性地照看着她的两个年幼的弟弟妹妹。7 岁的安娜·博蒙特是兄妹中更外向的一个，她有着丰富的想象力，可以自娱自乐几个小时。安娜性格外向、充满爱心，喜欢看书、跳舞、玩变装游戏，还喜欢组织她会在家人面前表演的音乐会，有时甚至会把她的弟弟和妹妹也拉进表演中。作为家里的老小，4 岁的格兰特·博蒙特二世是个充满活力、让父亲充满生机的小绅士。他会在家里像影子一样跟着吉姆，看着父亲完成家务，并假装是父亲的小助手。为了表现得像爸爸一样，格兰特会开着一辆红色的卡丁车四处飞驰，表现得好像那是一辆出租车。格兰特是一个甜美友善的小男孩，全家人都宠爱着他。吉姆·博蒙特作为一名旅行推销员的工作意味着他经常不得不在路上度过好几天的时间，虽然他不喜欢离开家人，但这为他们提供了一种朴素、舒适的生活方式。
To keep him up to date with the happenings at home, Jane would send her father handwritten letters detailing the little events of her day, which Jim would keep tucked safely in his briefcase to read each night for a reminder of home. One such letter read, But Aunty, Mummy and I swam in the three-foot six-inch pool. While we were there, I learnt how to open my eyes under the water forever so long, and I learnt how to kick my legs and make my arms float. And dive, gracefully dive, races dive and plane dive. I learnt all this from Aunty Tali. There is only one thing I can't do, breathing out as I'm swimming along. Tonight, I had a hot pie, fritz and sauce sandwich, and rainbow ice cream. Aunty Tali bought a great big roast chicken from her father for nothing. Most of all, I want to wish you much luck with your hot, tiring work.
为了让他了解家里的最新情况，简会给父亲写手写信，详细描述她白天的琐事，吉姆会把这些信安全地夹在公文包里，每天晚上阅读，以此作为对家的回忆。其中一封信写道：“但是阿姨，妈咪和我在那个三英尺六英寸深的游泳池里游泳了。在我们去的那段时间里，我学会了如何在水里睁开眼睛好久好久，我还学会了如何踢腿、让胳膊浮起来。还有跳水，优雅地跳水，赛跑跳水和平板跳水。这一切都是我从塔利阿姨那里学来的。只有一件事我不会，那就是一边游泳一边呼气。今晚，我吃了一个热派、弗里茨和酱汁三明治以及彩虹冰淇淋。塔利阿姨白白从她父亲那里买了一只非常大的烤鸡。最重要的是，我祝你辛苦又劳累的工作一切顺利。”
Well, goodbye, I have to go now. I love you. Loving, Jane. Whenever Jim managed to take time off work, he would take his family caravanning to visit his old army mates in Victoria, or explore different parts of South Australia. During one trip along the Great Ocean Road on Victoria's west coast, the family stopped at the iconic Twelve Apostles landmark. Jane and Anna sat on either side of Grant as the Beaumont children happily posed on the cliffs in front of the limestone stacks. The memory captured in a photograph. Jim and Nancy Beaumont cherished these holidays, savouring every moment the family were together. Music By 1966, the Beaumont family was living the Australian dream.
“嗯，再见，我得走了。我爱你。爱你的，简。”每当吉姆设法从工作中抽身时，他就会带着家人去维多利亚州房车露营，拜访他在军队的老战友，或者探索南澳大利亚的不同地区。在沿着维多利亚州西海岸的大洋路旅行期间，全家人在标志性的十二使徒岩地标停留。简和安娜坐在格兰特的两侧，博蒙特的孩子们开心地在石灰岩柱前的悬崖上摆姿势。这一记忆被一张照片定格。吉姆和南希·博蒙特十分珍视这些假期，细细品味着全家人在一起的每一个时刻。音乐 到 1966 年，博蒙特一家过着澳大利亚式的梦想生活。
Their suburban home on Harding Street in Summerton Park allowed them to take advantage of the iconic Aussie beach lifestyle. The seaside suburb of Glenelk was only a 20 minute walk away, and the Beaumonts, like many others, were regular visitors during the warmer months. The cool pristine waters of Glenelk Beach provided respite from the harsh Australian sun, and the stretch of golden sand was the ideal space for the kids to run around and play. South Australia's metropolitan coastline stretches for 30 kilometres from south to west. Glenelk blies towards its centre on the shores of Holdfast Bay, located 11 kilometres south west from Adelaide Central Business District. As the oldest European settlement on mainland South Australia, Glenelk is home to many historical hotels, restaurants and attractions which overlook the scenic sea front. During the summer months, the beach's flat, serene sea provides perfect swimming conditions for thousands of daily visitors. The central hub of Mosley Square frames the shores of the beach, intersected by the Glenelk to City Tram Line.
他们在萨默顿公园哈丁街的郊区住宅让他们能够充分享受标志性的澳大利亚海滩生活方式。格伦elg海滨郊区步行只需 20 分钟，和许多其他人一样，博蒙特一家在较温暖的月份里也是常客。格伦elg海滩凉爽纯净的海水让人从严酷的澳大利亚阳光中解脱出来，绵延的金沙是孩子们四处奔跑玩耍的理想场所。南澳大利亚的大都会海岸线从南到西延伸 30 公里。格伦elg位于其中心附近，坐落在霍尔德法斯特湾的海岸上，位于阿德莱德中央商务区西南 11 公里处。作为南澳大利亚大陆上最古老的欧洲定居点，格伦elg拥有许多俯瞰风景优美的海滨的历史悠久的酒店、餐厅和景点。在夏季，海滩平坦、平静的海水为每天成千上万的游客提供了完美的游泳条件。莫斯利广场的中央枢纽构成了海滩的海岸，与格伦elg至城市有轨电车路线相交。
Neighboring the square is Coley Reserve, an expanse of lush green lawns shadowed by tall pine trees, providing a popular space for picnics and sunbathing. Aside from cosmetic and modern refurbishments, the Glenelk beachfront and town surrounds are very much the same today as they were in the 1960s. Back then, the Glenelk jetty was in a state of disrepair after suffering extensive damage from a major storm in 1948 and had yet to be restored. In 1969, a much shorter jetty was constructed in its place, which remains standing today. In January 1966, Adelaide was experiencing a prolonged heatwave, with temperatures soaring towards 40 degrees Celsius. To cool off, the Beaumont family had spent a significant portion of the summer school holidays at Glenelk Beach. Jim Beaumont had been lucky enough to enjoy four weeks of holidays over the Christmas period, spending many days of his break at the beach with his children. Jim was officially back to work on Tuesday, January 25, and was to embark on the hot 150km journey to Snowtown for his first round of sales calls for the year.
与广场相邻的是科利保护区，这是一片郁郁葱葱的草坪，由高大的松树遮阴，为野餐和日光浴提供了一个受欢迎的空间。除了外观和现代化的翻新之外，格伦elg海滩和城镇周围与 20 世纪 60 年代几乎一模一样。当时，格伦elg码头在 1948 年的一场大风暴中遭受了广泛破坏后处于年久失修的状态，尚未修复。1969 年，在其原址上修建了一个短得多的码头，至今仍然屹立不倒。1966 年 1 月，阿德莱德经历了一场漫长热浪，气温飙升至 40 摄氏度左右。为了消暑，博蒙特一家在格伦elg海滩度过了学校暑假的很大一部分时间。吉姆·博蒙特很幸运地在圣诞节期间享受了四周的假期，他的很多休息日都是和孩子们一起在海滩上度过的。吉姆于 1 月 25 日星期二正式复工，并踏上了前往斯诺敦炎热的 150 公里旅程，开始了他这一年的第一轮销售拜访。
Before leaving that morning, Jim agreed to give his three kids a lift down to Glenelk Beach to save them from having to ride their bikes in the heat. Upon reaching the Glenelk foreshore, Jane, Anna, and Grant got out of their father's holding station wagon and rushed down to the beach. Like a majority of Aussie kids in the early 1960s, the Beaumont siblings enjoyed a great amount of independence. The quiet, close-knit suburbs of Adelaide were carefree and safe, where everybody knew their neighbours and looked out for one another. Spending time inside was discouraged, and parents typically sent their children outdoors alone to play for hours on end, urging them to return home before the streetlights flickered on at night. In the hot Australian summer, suburban streets, backyards, parks and beaches filled with local children who would gather to play games, sports, ride their bikes, and make new friends. Scrounging up enough loose change to buy ice creams, hot chips, mixed lollies, and soft drinks. These were the days before television sets were commonplace, before the whole in the ozone layer presented sun exposure threats, and before parents felt the prickling omnipresence of stranger danger.
那天早上出发前，吉姆同意顺车载他的三个孩子去格伦elg海滩，免得他们在炎热的天气里骑自行车。到达格伦elg滨海区后，简、安娜和格兰特从他们父亲霍顿旅行车里下来，冲向海滩。就像 20 世纪 60 年代初大多数澳大利亚孩子一样，博蒙特兄妹享有高度的独立性。阿德莱德安静、紧密联系的郊区无忧无虑且安全，每个人都认识邻居并守望相助。呆在家里是不被鼓励的，父母通常会把孩子单独送到户外玩几个小时，并敦促他们在晚上路灯闪烁之前回家。在炎热的澳大利亚夏天，郊区的街道、后院、公园和海滩挤满了当地的孩子，他们聚集在一起玩游戏、运动、骑自行车、结交新朋友。凑够零钱买冰淇淋、热薯条、什锦糖果和软饮料。这些都是电视机尚未普及、臭氧层空洞带来日晒威胁、以及父母感到陌生人危险无处不在的日子之前的事情。
Jim Beaumont trusted his three children completely. The maturity of his eldest daughter Jane served her younger siblings well. Jane confidently led Anna and Grant on summer outings, herding them on and off the bus, carrying Grant on her hip, and ensuring her little brother and sister never went deeper than their belly buttons when swimming in the ocean. They were good, sensible kids who took great care of each other and obeyed their parents' rules. Before Jim Beaumont drove onwards for his work trip, he sat in his car, observing contentedly as his three children played on the beach. Four-year-old son Grant caught sight of his father watching and ran towards him, waving happily and calling, Go on daddy, don't worry. The following day of Wednesday, January 26, 1966, Nancy Beaumont woke at 7am after another hot and sticky night's sleep. She lay in bed, enjoying the peace and quiet before her children arose.
吉姆·博蒙特完全信任他的三个孩子。大女儿简的成熟很好地照顾了她的弟弟妹妹。简自信地带领安娜和格兰特进行夏日郊游，引导他们上下公交车，把格兰特夹在臀部，并确保她的弟弟妹妹在海洋中游泳时绝不越过肚脐。他们是善良、懂事的孩子，彼此照顾得很好，并遵守父母的规则。在吉姆·博蒙特开车继续他的工作之旅之前，他坐在车里，满意地看着他的三个孩子在海滩上玩耍。4 岁的儿子格兰特看到父亲在看他，便朝他跑去，开心地挥着手喊道：“去吧，爸爸，别担心。”第二天，即 1966 年 1 月 26 日星期三，南希·博蒙特在又一个闷热黏糊的夜晚睡眠后，于早上 7 点醒来。她躺在床上，享受着孩子们起床前的安宁与寂静。
It wasn't long before Anna and Grant burst excitedly into their mother's room, jumping on Nancy's bed and asking if they could spend the day at the beach. School was due to recommence the following week, and the kids wanted to make the most of their remaining time off together while they still could. It was Australia Day, a national holiday that marks the anniversary of the arrival of the first fleet of British ships to Australian shores. Although the accompanying public holiday was anticipated for the upcoming weekend, Glenelk Beach was still guaranteed to attract thousands of visitors that Wednesday, eager to join in on the day's festivities. Unlike the rest of her family, Nancy Beaumont didn't care much for the beach, but with her husband away for work, she was the only one available to accompany the children to Glenelk. She agreed to consider taking them once her daily housework was complete. After breakfast, the Beaumont children were becoming impatient. As Nancy had several chores she had to finish, she caved in and agreed to let her children go to Glenelk on their own.
没过多久，安娜和格兰特兴奋地冲进母亲的房间，跳上南希的床，问他们是否可以在海滩度过一天。学校定于下周开学，孩子们想在他们还能做主的时候，充分利用剩下的假期时间。今天是澳大利亚日，这是一个全国性的节日，标志着第一支英国船队抵达澳大利亚海岸的周年纪念。尽管随后的公共假期预计将在接下来的周末到来，但格伦elg海滩仍然保证在那个星期三吸引成千上万的游客，他们急切地想要加入当天的庆祝活动。与家里的其他人不同，南希·博蒙特不太关心海滩，但由于丈夫因公外出，她是唯一一个可以陪孩子们去格伦elg的人。她同意在日常家务完成后考虑带他们去。早饭后，博蒙特的孩子们变得不耐烦了。由于南希有几项必须完成的家务，她妥协了，同意让孩子们自己去格伦elg。
It was a trip the three had made without parental supervision many times before, and with the wise and mature Jane leading them, Nancy had nothing to worry about. While it was only a short walk and even shorter bike ride to Glenelk, it was far too hot for the children to make the journey on foot. The diagonal road bus stop was only 100 metres away from the Beaumont's house, and the bus route led straight into Glenelk, stopping on Mosley Street, a short walk from the beach. Nancy decided catching the bus would be the quickest and therefore best option for Jane, Anna and Grant. The eager Beaumont children quickly dressed in their bathing suits. The eldest, Jane wore pink one-piece bathers with pale green shorts and tartan canvas sand shoes. Middle child, Anna wore red and white striped one-piece bathers with tan shorts and tan sandals. The youngest, Grant wore green and white bathers with green cotton shorts, red leather sandals, and remained shirtless.
这是三个孩子以前没有父母监督的情况下过很多次的旅程，在聪明成熟的简的带领下，南希没有什么可担心的。虽然到格伦elg只有短短的步行路程，骑自行车甚至更快，但对孩子们来说，步行完成这段旅程实在是太热了。对角路公交车站距离博蒙特家只有 100 米，公交车路线直通格伦elg，在莫斯利街停靠，距离海滩仅几步之遥。南希决定乘公交车是简、安娜和格兰特最快、因此也是最好的选择。急切的博蒙特孩子们迅速换上了泳衣。老大简穿着粉红色连体泳衣，搭配浅绿色短裤和格子帆布沙滩鞋。老二安娜穿着红白相间条纹连体泳衣，搭配棕褐色短裤和棕褐色凉鞋。最小的格兰特穿着绿白相间的泳衣，搭配绿色纯棉短裤、红色皮质凉鞋，赤着上身。
Jane packed three beach towels into a green airline-style shoulder bag, along with a paperback copy of the novel Little Women. Nancy handed her eldest daughter eight shillings and sixpence to use for bus fares and lunch, which Jane carefully placed inside a white clip-top purse. They were instructed to use the change from their lunch to buy tickets on the midday bus home. After the children out of the house, it didn't take Nancy long to finish her housework. At around 10.30am, she jumped on her bike and rode over to visit a friend who lived nearby. Five minutes before the midday bus from Glenelk was due to arrive, Nancy rode to the diagonal road stop to meet up with her children. However, when the bus arrived, the only person to disembark was an elderly woman. Nancy suspected her kids must have missed the midday bus and would instead jump on the following bus, which would arrive to the diagonal road stop around 2pm.
简将三条沙滩拖进一个绿色的航空风格单肩包里，里面还有一本平装版的小说《小妇人》。南希递给大女儿八先令六便士用于车费和午餐，简小心翼翼地把它放进一个白色的夹扣钱包里。他们被指示用午餐找零买中午回家公交车的票。孩子们出门后，南希没花多久就做完了家务。大约上午 10:30，她骑上自行车去拜访住在附近的一个朋友。在格伦elg的中午公交车到达前五分钟，南希骑车到对角路车站去接孩子们。然而，当公交车到达时，下车的唯一一个人是一位老妇人。南希猜测她的孩子们一定错过了中午的公交车，而是会坐下一班车，该车大约在下午 2 点到达对角路车站。
Unconcerned, Nancy rode home. Soon after she arrived, a couple of friends stopped by for a surprise visit. During their stay, Nancy kept a watchful eye on the clock, but 2pm ticked by and still there was no sign of Jane, Anna or Grant. She reminded herself that the kids knew the local area like the back of their hands and there were several different routes they may have taken to walk home if they missed the bus. Nancy decided to wait a short while longer as the 3pm bus would be arriving at the diagonal road stop from Glenelk soon and there was a likely chance her children would be on board. Shortly before 3pm, Jim Beaumont's Holden station wagon unexpectedly pulled into the driveway. He wasn't scheduled to return home from Snowtown until the following day, but as sales were slow in the weeks following Christmas holidays, Jim thought his time would be better spent at home with his family. Nancy informed her husband that their kids hadn't returned home from the beach and she was starting to worry.
南希并不担心，骑着车回了家。她刚到不久，几个朋友就顺道来了一个惊喜拜访。在他们逗留期间，南希一直盯着时钟，但下午 2 点过去了，依然没有简、安娜或格兰特的踪影。她提醒自己，孩子们对当地了如指掌，如果他们错过了公交车，他们可能会选择几条不同的路线步行回家。南希决定再等一会儿，因为下午 3 点的公交车很快就会从格伦elg到达对角路车站，而且她的孩子们很可能会在车上。下午 3 点前不久，吉姆·博蒙特的霍顿旅行车出乎意料地驶入了车道。他本计划第二天才能从斯诺敦回家，但由于圣诞假期后几周的销售缓慢，吉姆认为他的时间最好花在家里的家人身上。南希告诉丈夫，他们的孩子还没有从海滩回家，她开始担心了。
Jim assured Nancy there was nothing to be worried about, believing they would have heard something by now if an accident had occurred. It was the same thing Nancy had been telling herself all afternoon, reassured by the fact that an accident injuring all three children was highly unlikely. She was thankful for the fact that if one child was hurt, the other two were there to seek help. She had always believed in safety in numbers. There was still no sign of the children by 3.30pm. Nancy waited expectantly at home in case they arrived at any moment, while Jim drove to Glenelk to see if they were still there. The seaside town was packed with thousands of people, making it impossible for Jim to spot his children through the crowds. He returned home to pick up Nancy and the pair combed to the beach. Their initial concern quickly growing into full-blown panic as they failed to uncover any sign of their children. At 5.30pm, Jim and Nancy Beaumont walked into the Glenelk police station in Mosley Square and declared their three children, Jane, Anna and Grant, to be missing. The constable at the Glenelk police station took a description of the Beaumont children, but assured their concerned parents everything would be okay.
吉姆向南希保证没什么好担心的，他认为如果发生了事故，他们现在应该已经听到消息了。这也是南希整个下午一直在对自我重复的话，因为三个孩子全部受伤的可能性极低，这让她感到安心。她很庆幸，如果一个孩子受伤了，另外两个孩子会在那里寻求帮助。她一直坚信人多安全。到了下午 3 点半，依然没有孩子的踪影。南希焦急地在家等待，以防他们随时回来，而吉姆则开车去格伦elg看看他们是否还在那里。海滨小镇挤满了成千上万的人，吉姆根本无法在人群中认出他的孩子们。他回到家接上南希，两人在海滩上搜寻起来。由于未能发现任何孩子的踪迹，他们最初的担忧迅速演变成全面的恐慌。下午 5 点半，吉姆和南希·博蒙特走进莫斯利广场的格伦elg警察局，宣布他们的三个孩子简、安娜和格兰特失踪。格伦elg警察局的警员记录了博蒙特孩子的体貌特征，但向他们焦躁不安的父母保证一切都会好的。
An abduction involving three children was unheard of, so the constable was certain the kids had either lost track of time, lost their way home, or had been involved in an accident. Nonetheless, he called police headquarters in Adelaide to file the report. Jim and Nancy returned home to Harding Street, disheartened to find the kids hadn't returned during their absence. Soon after, two police officers arrived to conduct a search of the Beaumont house, believing there was a chance the children were simply hiding from their parents to avoid getting in trouble for failing to meet their curfew. When this search proved fruitless, the officers began a more detailed line of questioning with Nancy Beaumont, asking for exact information about what the children were wearing and what time they had left home. She described her children. 9-year-old Jane was 4'6 inches tall, thin, with freckles and sun-bleached hair cropped to her ears with a pushed-back fringe at the front. 7-year-old Anna was 4 foot tall, of plump build, with suntanned skin and short, dark brown hair with a fringe. 4-year-old Grant was just 3 foot tall, thin, with short brown hair and a nollie complexion, with very suntanned skin.
涉及三个孩子的绑架事件闻所未闻，因此警员确信孩子们要么是忘记了时间，要么是迷路了，或者发生了事故。尽管如此，他还是打电话给阿德莱德警察总部提交了报告。吉姆和南希回到哈丁街的家，沮丧地发现孩子们在他们离开期间并没有回来。不久之后，两名警官到达对博蒙特家进行搜查，他们认为孩子们可能只是在躲避父母，以避免因未能在宵禁前回家而惹上麻烦。当这次搜查证明毫无结果时，警官们开始对南希·博蒙特进行更详细的询问，要求提供关于孩子们穿着什么以及他们是什么时候离开家的确切信息。她描述了她的孩子。9 岁的简身高 4 英尺 6 英寸，身材消瘦，长着雀斑和被阳光晒成金色的头发，剪到耳边，前面有向后推的刘海。7 岁的安娜身高 4 英尺，身材微胖，皮肤晒黑，留着短而黑的棕色头发和刘海。4 岁的格兰特身高只有 3 英尺，身材消瘦，留着短棕色头发，肤色白皙，皮肤晒得很黑。
The police left to search Glenelg and the surrounding Summerton Park streets with a frantic Jim Beaumont in tow. They searched the coastlines of Glenelg, Summerton, West Beach, Sea Cliff and Brighton, looking for any sign of the children, including the bag, towels and clothing they had left the house with that morning. The hot temperature made the search extra challenging as the beaches were still packed with crowds of people late into the night. Jim Beaumont quickly ruled out the possibility his children drowned in the sea, later stating, quote, The beaches were packed and the sea was calm. One kitty, perhaps, could be drowned, but the three together, I just can't imagine that. There would have been some evidence. They had their green beach bag with them. They had their clothes. I found nothing like that at all. Struggling to see properly in the dark, the police called off the search until the morning light. Jim Beaumont vowed that he wouldn't return home without his children and continued to search the streets and beaches alone until 7am. Supported by friends and neighbours, Nancy Beaumont kept vigil at home as word of the children's disappearance trickled onto late night radio news and television reports.
警察离开去搜寻格伦elg和萨默顿公园周边的街道，随行的还有情绪崩溃的吉姆·博蒙特。他们搜寻了格伦elg、萨默顿、西海滩、海崖和布赖顿的海岸线，寻找孩子们的任何踪迹，包括他们那天早上离开家时随身携带的包、毛巾和衣服。炎热的气温使搜寻工作格外具有挑战性，因为直到深夜，海滩上依然挤满了人群。吉姆·博蒙特迅速排除了他的孩子在海中溺水的可能性，后来他宣称：“海滩上挤满了人，海面很平静。一个小孩可能会溺水，但三个孩子在一起，我简直无法想象。会留下一些证据的。他们随身带着绿色的沙滩包。他们带着衣服。我根本没有找到类似的东西。”由于天黑看得不是很清楚，警方暂停了搜查，直到晨光熹微。吉姆·博蒙特发誓，如果没有找到他的孩子，他是不会回家的，并独自一人继续在街道和海滩上搜寻，直到早上 7 点。在朋友和邻居的支持下，南希·博蒙特在家中守夜，而孩子们失踪的消息则通过深夜广播新闻和电视报道逐渐传开。
Nancy wondered whether her children had fallen into a hole or down a cliff. The children's love for one another was strong and if one was hurt, the other two would never abandon them. All three were afraid of the dark and they may have taken shelter somewhere for the night. The possibility of abduction crossed Nancy's mind, but the idea of someone kidnapping three children at once seemed so far-fetched that she quickly dismissed the prospect. Racked with guilt, Nancy blamed herself for allowing her children to go to the beach alone that morning. The increasing fear that her children were deceased fuelled such intense anxiety in Nancy. Her local doctor was called to the house to administer her a strong sedative. When an exhausted Jim Beaumont returned home from his futile search, he found his wife slumped in a chair in a medicated sleep. Her face stained with tears. The extensive police search for the Beaumont children resumed at daylight the following morning on Thursday, January 27. Five boats from the Sea Rescue Squadron scanned the Glenelk shoreline while officers trudged on foot through stormwater drains, sand dunes and dense scrub.
南希想知道她的孩子们是否掉进了洞里或悬崖下。孩子们之间的感情很深厚，如果一个人受伤了，另外两个绝对不会抛弃他们。三个人都怕黑，他们可能在某个地方找了个地方过夜。绑架的可能性掠过南希的脑海，但绑架三个孩子的想法听起来太牵强了，她很快就把这个想法抛诸脑后。内疚感折磨着南希，她责怪自己那天早上允许孩子们独自去海滩。对孩子们已经遇难的日益增长的恐惧在南希心中引发了强烈的焦虑。她家的医生被叫到家里给她注射了强效镇静剂。当筋疲力尽的吉姆·博蒙特结束了徒劳的搜寻回到家时，他发现妻子瘫倒在椅子上，在药物的作用下睡着了。她的脸上满是泪水。第二天早上，即 1 月 27 日星期四天亮时，警方对博蒙特孩子的广泛搜查恢复了。来自海上救援中队的五艘船只扫描了格伦elg海岸线，而警官们则步行穿过雨水渠、沙丘和茂密的灌木丛。
Police from city and suburban patrols joined the ongoing search, conducting door knocks and checking backyards, sheds and vacant properties. Police issued detailed descriptions of the children's physical features and clothing to the media while police cars fitted with loudspeakers drove the streets of Glenelk appealing for help. By mid-morning, Jim Beaumont addressed gathering members of the press on the back porch of his Harding Street home. Sick with worry and struggling from sleep deprivation, he pleaded desperately for his children to come home, telling the media, quote, It's a complete mystery. I can't understand it. My kids will be crying their eyes out. It's like a nightmare. Overwhelmed with emotion, Jim bowed his head and broke down in tears. Nancy Beaumont was too distraught to face anyone and remained indoors in a medicated fog. As news of the disappearance spread, the Glenelk police station was quickly inundated with information from the public.
来自城市和郊区巡逻队的警察加入了持续的搜查，进行了挨家挨户的走访，并检查了后院、棚屋和空置房屋。警方向媒体发布了孩子们体貌特征和衣着的详细描述，同时配备扬声器的警车在格伦elg的街道上行驶，呼吁人们提供帮助。到上午中期，吉姆·博蒙特在哈丁街家中的后门廊上向聚集的媒体发表了讲话。由于担心而生病并饱受睡眠不足的折磨，他绝望地恳求他的孩子回家，对媒体说：“这是一个完全的谜。我无法理解。我的孩子们一定会哭得眼睛都肿了。这就像一场噩梦。”吉姆情绪失控，低下头放声大哭。南希·博蒙特悲痛欲绝，无法面对任何人，一直呆在室内的药物迷雾中。随着失踪消息的传开，格伦elg警察局很快被公众提供的信息淹没。
People wishing to speak to police had formed a line that stretched 20 metres long outside the door. With just one sergeant and four detectives, the Glenelk police station was ill-equipped to handle the unexpected and the large-scale case. For the small team, interviewing every single person and following every possible lead was impossible. They painstakingly typed each given statement using the station's only typewriter. The search for the missing Beaumont children quickly escalated into a statewide frenzy. Police roadblocks were established on all major South Australian highways, and Adelaide's airport and derailway station were put under heavy surveillance. Members of the public volunteered their time to wade in the search, including taxi drivers who had previously worked with Jim Beaumont. They cruised the streets in their cabs, while members of Jane Beaumont's brownie pack rode their bikes around the surrounding neighbourhoods, searching for their missing friend.
想要与警方交谈的人在门外排成了 20 米长的队伍。格伦elg警察局只有一名警长和四名侦探，根本无法应对这起意料之外的大规模案件。对于这支小团队来说，采访每一个人并跟进每一个可能的线索是不可能的。他们用警察局仅有的一台打字机辛苦地打出每一份给出的证词。对失踪的博蒙特孩子的搜查迅速升级为全州范围内的狂热。南澳大利亚的所有主要高速公路上都设立了警察路障，阿德莱德的机场和火车站也受到了严密监视。公众自愿抽出时间参与搜查，其中包括以前与吉姆·博蒙特合作过的出租车司机。他们开着出租车在街道上巡逻，而简·博蒙特的布朗尼女童子军成员则骑着自行车在周边社区寻找他们失踪的朋友。
Three kids matching the ages of the Beaumont children were sighted at 7pm on the night the siblings vanished. The children were seen standing by the water's edge at the Patawalonga Boathaven, a marina just one kilometre north from Colley Reserve. A woman spoke to the children briefly, and they had informed her that they didn't live in the area. Given the high profile and urgency of the Beaumont children case, police were taking no chances. The marina, which had a surface covering 70 acres and a depth of 6 feet, was drained for the first time since its establishment in 1959. In what would become one of the largest single searches for the Beaumont children so far, 80 young police cadets dragged themselves through the thick, black, foul-smelling mud at the bottom of the empty marina. Using broomsticks, they prodded the mud for any sign of the missing children, but to no avail.
在兄妹失踪当晚的晚上 7 点，有人看到了三个与博蒙特孩子年龄相仿的孩子。这些孩子们被看到站在帕塔瓦隆加船坞的水边，这是一个距离科利保护区以北仅一公里的码头。一名女子简短地与孩子们交谈过，他们告诉她他们不住在该地区。鉴于博蒙特儿童案的高度关注和紧迫性，警方没有放过任何机会。该码头占地 70 英亩，水深 6 英尺，自 1959 年建成以来首次被抽干。在迄今为止对博蒙特孩子最大规模的单独搜查之一中，80 名年轻的警校学员在空码头底部厚重、黑色、散发着恶臭的泥浆中跋涉。他们用扫帚柄在泥浆中探寻失踪孩子的任何迹象，但无济于事。
Despite these efforts, not a single piece of evidence was located to indicate where the children had gone. It was determined that the siblings left home carrying around 17 or so items with them, including bags, clothes, towels, as well as Jane's book and purse. None of these items were recovered at any of the key locations the children were expected to have travelled, nor were they spotted on the shoreline of Glenelg Beach. This made the possibility the trio had drowned all the more unlikely, given their belongings would have been left behind on the sand and later discovered. The search for Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont soon became the most extensive missing person search in South Australian history. Within the first 48 hours of the Beaumont children's disappearance, police had received hundreds of calls from people claiming to have seen the three young siblings.
尽管做出了这些努力，但没有找到任何能够表明孩子们去过哪里的证据。据确定，兄妹离开家时随身携带了大约 17 件左右的物品，包括包、衣服、毛巾，以及简的书和钱包。在孩子们预计去过的任何关键地点都没有找回这些物品，格伦elg海滩的海岸线上也没有发现它们。这使得三人溺水的可能性变得更加不可能，因为他们的物品本应留在沙滩上并在后来被发现。对简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特的搜查很快成为南澳大利亚历史上规模最大的失踪人口搜查。在博蒙特孩子失踪的前 48 小时内，警方接到了数百个自称见过这三个年幼兄妹的电话。
One woman claimed to have seen a man and three children enter a vacant house opposite her home in Adelaide's eastern suburbs, but the group was mysteriously gone the next day. Another believed she saw the three children accompanied by two men sitting at a bus stop multiple suburbs away in Semaphore Park. Most reported sightings led nowhere, all were ruled out completely, but with the help of several reliable corroborating witness statements, detectives were able to piece together what was likely to have been Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont's movements prior to their disappearance. While reports from witnesses who believed they saw the children on the morning of January 26th varied in specifics, there was enough information provided for police to establish a fairly reliable timeline and identify several potential leads.
一位女士声称看到一名男子和三个孩子进入了阿德莱德东郊她家对面的一栋空房子，但第二天这群人神秘地消失了。另一位女士相信她看到这三个孩子在两个男人的陪同下坐在几个郊区之外的塞马福尔公园的公交车站。大多数报告的目击事件都没有结果，全部被彻底排除，但在几份可靠的佐证证词的帮助下，侦探们得以拼凑出简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特在失踪前可能的活动轨迹。虽然目击者关于 1 月 26 日上午看到孩子们的具体细节各不相同，但提供的信息足以让警方建立一个相当可靠的时间线并确定几个潜在的线索。
At approximately 10.15am, Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont boarded a public transit bus to Glenelg from the diagonal road stop as confirmed by the driver. An older couple travelling on the bus recalled Jane Beaumont sitting on the backseat reading Little Women while Anna and Grant messed around, cheekily putting their arms out of the windows just to get a rise out of their older sister. The bus arrived to Glenelg just a few minutes later and the siblings disembarked on Mosley Street several streets back from the seafront. Local postman Tom Patterson, who knew the Beaumont family from his daily mail route, saw Jane, Anna and Grant walking along Mosley Street holding hands and laughing. Tom heard one of the children yell out to the others, look there's our postie and a little Grant waved hello.
据司机证实，大约上午 10:15，简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特在对角路车站登上了一辆开往格伦elg的公共交通公交车。车上的一对老年夫妇回忆说，简·博蒙特坐在后座上读《小妇人》，而安娜和格兰特则在胡闹，调皮地把胳膊伸出窗外，只是为了惹恼他们的姐姐。几分钟后，公交车抵达格伦elg，兄妹俩在距离海滨几条街开外的莫斯利街下了车。当地邮递员汤姆·帕特森在日常送信途中认识博蒙特一家，他看到简、安娜和格兰特手拉着手、笑着沿莫斯利街走着。汤姆听到其中一个孩子向其他人喊道：“看，那是我们的邮递员，”小格兰特挥手打招呼。
Tom struggled to recall the exact time he saw the Beaumont children, uncertain if it was in the morning or afternoon, but police believed the sighting occurred as the children first headed to the beach. Several witnesses observed the Beaumont children playing in the shallow waters just north of the Glenelg Jetty, which formed the busiest section of the beach. It was the same area they had swam in the day before when their father dropped them off before his work trip to Snowtown. Anna and Grant were only comfortable splashing in the shallows and had never ventured beyond a waist deep. Shortly after 11am the children finished swimming and made the short walk from the Jetty to Collie Reserve where they laid their towels out on the lawn.
汤姆记不清看到博蒙特孩子们的具体时间，不确定是在上午还是下午，但警方认为目击事件发生在孩子们首次前往海滩时。几名目击者观察到博蒙特孩子们在格伦elg码头正北面的浅水区玩耍，这里是海滩最繁忙的地段。这正是前一天他们的父亲在去斯诺敦工作之旅前放下他们时游泳的同一个区域。安娜和格兰特只满足于在浅水区戏水，从未冒险超过腰部深度。上午 11 点刚过，孩子们结束了游泳，从码头步行一小段路来到科利保护区，把毛巾铺在草坪上。
Earlier they were witnessed playing under a water sprinkler as they washed sand off their feet. This sighting was further corroborated by a school friend of Jane Beaumonts who saw the siblings at the reserve at around 11.25am. An elderly woman sitting on a bench in front of the nearby Holdfast sailing club observed a man approach the Beaumont children as they played out on the lawn. He was described to be in his 30s, 6 foot tall with an athletic build, tanned skin, long face, high forehead and wavy blonde hair. He wore navy blue bae the briefs with a distinctive white stripe. After speaking to Jane and her younger siblings, the man placed his own towel on the grass a few feet away, then lay on his stomach and watched the children play.
此前，有人目击他们在洒水器下玩耍，冲洗掉脚上的沙子。简·博蒙特的一位学校朋友进一步证实了这一目击事件，她在上午 11 点 25 分左右在保护区看到了兄妹俩。一位坐在附近霍尔德法斯特帆船俱乐部前面的长椅上的老妇人看到一名男子在博蒙特孩子们在草坪上玩耍时走近他们。据描述，他 30 多岁，身高 6 英尺，身材健美，皮肤晒黑，长脸，高额头，留着波浪状的金发。他穿着深蓝色泳裤，带有醒目的白色条纹。在与简和她的弟弟妹妹交谈后，这名男子将自己的毛巾铺在几英尺外的草地上，然后趴在草地上看着孩子们玩耍。
Within 15 minutes of the man's arrival, the children were seen jumping over him, the oldest girl playfully clicking him and her siblings with her towel. A half hour later, the elderly woman observing the group left Collie Reserve, noting the man and her children were still frolicking together on the lawn when she departed. Sometime between 11.30am and midday, the Beaumont children entered Wenzel's cake shop on Moseley Street where they often purchased their lunch when in town. The bakery was located right next to the bus stop the siblings would use to get back home to Summerton Park. These actions seemed to be in line with their original plan to buy lunch and return home by midday as advised by their mother.
在该男子到达后的 15 分钟内，孩子们被看到从他身上跳过去，大女孩顽皮地用毛巾拍打着他她的弟弟妹妹。半小时后，观察该团体的老妇人离开了科利保护区，并注意到当她离开时，该男子和孩子们仍然在草坪上嬉戏。在上午 11:30 到中午之间的某个时间，博蒙特孩子们进入了莫斯利街上的文策尔蛋糕店，他们在镇上时经常在那里买午餐。面包店就在兄妹俩回家去萨默顿公园时要乘坐的公交车站旁边。这些行为似乎符合他们的原计划，即按照母亲的建议买午餐并在中午前回家。
Nancy Beaumont had given Jane eight shillings and six pints in silver coins to purchase lunch for her and her younger siblings, enough for each of the children to buy a pasty and have enough left over for the bus fare home. At Wenzel's bakery, the three children purchased five pasties, six finger buns and two large bottles of soft drink. One of the children also stated something along the lines of, and a pie for the man. It was an unusual request given the children had arrived to the store alone and the shopkeeper who had served the Beaumont children in the past did not recall them ever purchasing a meat pie before. This large order far exceeded the amount of food the children required for lunch whilst racking up a bill beyond what they could afford with the modest amount of money given to them by their mother.
南希·博蒙特给了简八先令六便士的银币，用来为她和她的弟弟妹妹买午餐，这笔钱足够每个孩子买一个肉饼，并且有足够的钱支付回家的车费。在文策尔面包店，三个孩子买了五个肉饼、六个手指面包卷和两大瓶软饮料。其中一个孩子还说了一些类似这样的话：“还有一个给这个男人的派。”这是一个不同寻常的请求，因为孩子们是独自到达商店的，而曾经服务过博蒙特孩子的店员并不记得他们以前买过肉饼。这份大额订单远远超过了孩子们午餐所需的食物量，同时产生了一笔账单，超出了他们用母亲给的微薄金额所能负担的范围。
But when it came time to pay, the children handed over a one pound note, a significant amount in 1966 and more money than the Beaumont children ever had access to. After leaving the bakery around midday, the children did not go straight to the bus stop and return home as expected. Instead, minutes later, they were spotted back in Collie Reserve, this time near the Glenelg Surf Club building. An elderly couple sitting on a bench saw the three children arrive and start speaking to the same tall blonde-haired man seen playing with the children earlier. This unknown man then approached the elderly couple seated nearby and within earshot of the children asked if they had seen anyone going through their belongings.
但到了付钱的时候，孩子们交出了一张一英镑的钞票，这在 1966 年是一笔巨款，比博蒙特孩子们曾经接触过的钱还要多。中午左右离开面包店后，孩子们并没有像预期那样径直走向公交车站回家。相反，几分钟后，他们被发现在科利保护区再次出现，这次是在格伦elg冲浪俱乐部大楼附近。一对坐在长椅上的老年夫妇看到三个孩子到达，并开始与早些时候看到和孩子们一起玩的那个高个子金发男子交谈。这个未知的男子随后走近坐在附近的这对老年夫妇，在孩子们听得到的范围内问他们是否看到有人翻找他们的物品。
He exclaimed, someone's nicked our money. This conversation was overheard by another woman close by who watched as the man returned to the children and began helping the young Beaumont girls put their shorts on over their bathers. The woman noted the action as odd as the oldest girl looked much too old to require assistance getting dressed. The man then went into the chain sheds behind the Surf Club building to get dressed, taking nothing but a pair of trousers and a towel. The three children patiently waited for him on a bench outside and were still there when the elderly couple left Collie Reserve at around 12.15pm.
他大声喊道：“有人偷了我们的钱。”附近的另一名女子无意中听到了这段对话，她看到该男子回到孩子们身边，并开始帮助年轻的博蒙特女孩们把短裤穿在泳衣外面。该女子注意到这个举动很奇怪，因为最大的女孩看起来太大了，不需要穿衣方面的帮助。然后，男子走进冲浪俱乐部大楼后面的更衣室换衣服，只带了一条裤子和一条毛巾。三个孩子们耐心地坐在外面的长椅上等他，大约 12 点 15 分这对老年夫妇离开科利保护区时，他们依然在那里。
After this, there were no further reported sightings of the man, or of Jane, Anna, or Grant Beaumont. Based on witness descriptions, a sketch of the unknown man last seen with the Beaumont children was drawn up. Witnesses could remember certain physical features but not other distinguishing characteristics such as the colour of his eyes or the shape of his nose or mouth. This led to a vague sketch with the artist left to fill in the gaps using his own creative interpretation. This rough sketch was widely circulated and although it didn't lead to a positive ID, it did prompt another witness into coming forward. The witness provided additional details about the man's appearance,
在此之后，再也没有关于该男子或简、安娜或格兰特·博蒙特的目击报告。根据目击者的描述，绘制了一张最后一次与博蒙特孩子们在一起的未知男子的素描。目击者能记住某些身体特征，但记不清其他显着的特征，例如眼睛的颜色或鼻子或嘴巴的形状。这导致了一张模糊的素描，艺术家不得不利用自己的创造性解释来填补空白。这张粗略的素描被广泛流传，尽管它没有带来确切的身份确认，但确实促使另一位目击者站了出来。目击者提供了关于该男子外貌的更多细节，
describing him as being in his late 30s or early 40s with a slim build and fair to light brown hair parted on the left hand side. The sketch was subsequently updated but the man it portrayed never came forward to clear himself, making him the lead suspect in the Beaumont children's disappearance. According to witnesses, the Beaumont children appeared completely at ease in the company of the unknown man and did not seem at all distressed. Based on this information, police suspected Australia Day was not the first time they had all met and the man may have frequented the Glenelg area or have already been known to the children in some other capacity. Arna Beaumont had recently told her mother that Jane had a boyfriend down at the beach, a comment that Nancy had brushed off innocently at the time,
形容他三十多岁或四十岁出头，身材苗条，有一头金发或浅棕色的头发，左分头。这幅素描随后被更新，但画像中的男子从未出面澄清自己，这使他成为博蒙特孩子们失踪案的主要嫌疑人。据目击者称，博蒙特的孩子们在这个陌生男子的陪伴下显得非常放松，一点也没有痛苦的样子。基于这些信息，警方怀疑澳大利亚日并不是他们第一次见面，这个男子可能经常光顾格莱内格地区，或者已经以其他某种身份被孩子们所认识。阿尔娜·博蒙特最近刚告诉她的母亲，简在海滩上交了一个男朋友，当时南希天真地把这句话当作玩笑打发了过去，
but now had her questioning whether the unknown man could have been Jane's hypothetical crush. The witness who saw the man help a Jane get dressed further added to this theory. Nancy Beaumont described Jane as a shy, modest girl who was very particular about her body. It would be uncharacteristic of her to permit a total stranger to touch her in such an intimate way. Investigators developed the theory that the unknown man was a pedophile who may have been grooming the Beaumont children during their unsupervised visits to Glenelg, building a rapport with the siblings over time. Spotting them unsupervised on Australia Day may have presented him with a clear opportunity to target them,
但现在她开始怀疑这个陌生的男子是否就是简假想中的追求者。那个看到该男子帮简穿衣服的目击者进一步印证了这一理论。南希·博蒙特将简描述为一个害羞、内向的女孩，对自己的身体非常讲究。让她允许一个完全陌生的男子以如此亲密的方式触摸自己，是不符合她的性格的。调查人员得出一个理论：这个陌生男子可能是一个恋童癖，在博蒙特孩子们无人看管地造访格莱内格期间，可能一直在对他们进行诱骗，随着时间的推移与这几兄妹建立了信任关系。在澳大利亚日发现他们无人看管，可能为他提供了一个清晰的目标，
a wolf in sheep's clothing. It seemed like no coincidence that when Jane and her siblings were due to take the bus home, her money had mysteriously disappeared. The police considering the likely scenario that the man himself had pocketed the child's money or purse, feigning concern and maintaining the deception by questioning park visitors about the supposed theft. The £1 note the children used in the bakery was perhaps one last act by the perpetrator to secure his prey. A generous offer to the down and out kids to spend lavishly on their lunch. Having earned their trust, the man may have then offered to take Jane, Anna and Grant home.
披着羊皮的狼。当简和她的弟弟妹妹们准备坐公交车回家时，她的钱却神秘地失踪了，这似乎并非巧合。警方认为很有可能发生的情况是，男子自己把孩子的钱或钱包揣进了口袋，假装关切并通过盘问公园游客关于所谓的偷窃事件来维持骗局。孩子们在面包店里使用的那张1英镑纸币，也许是罪犯确保猎物的最后一次行动。对落魄潦草的孩子们慷慨大方地让他们在午餐上大肆挥霍。在赢得他们的信任之后，该男子可能随后主动提出带简、阿尔娜和格兰特回家。
This theory would have the children willingly leaving Coley Reserve with their abductor, without drawing any attention to themselves or sensing any danger. For Jim Beaumont, the possibility that his children had been abducted seemed plausible. He told the media, quote, Jim speculated that an abductor may have been observing the children for some time, watching as they played in their parents' presence at the beach over the summer. Upon noticing they had no adult supervision on Australia Day, the abductor may have seen it as the perfect opportunity to strike.
这个理论认为，孩子们是自愿离开科利保护区跟随他们的绑架者的，没有引起任何人的注意，也没有感到任何危险。对于吉姆·博蒙特来说，他的孩子被绑架的可能性似乎是合乎情理的。他告诉媒体，引用吉姆推测，绑架者可能已经观察了孩子们一段时间，看着他们在父母在场的情况下整个夏天都在海滩上玩耍。在注意到他们在澳大利亚日没有成年人看管时，绑架者可能认为这是下手的绝佳机会。
They might have approached Jane, Anna and Grant and lied to lure the children into their vehicle, perhaps by offering to go for a surprise visit to see their father, or fabricating a story about their parents being involved in an accident. The fear that her children were being held captive led Nancy Beaumont to tell a journalist for the Herald newspaper, quote, I think as a mother, I'd rather kill the children myself and get it over quickly than have them at the mercy of some bad person for so long. Running with the theory that Beaumont children had been abducted by a pedophile, the Sunday Mail newspaper printed a story that played on every parent's worst nightmares.
他们可能接近了简、阿尔娜和格兰特，并撒谎将孩子们诱骗进他们的车里，也许是通过提供一次惊喜拜访去见他们的父亲，或者编造了一个关于他们的父母卷入事故的故事。害怕孩子们被囚禁的恐惧促使南希·博蒙特对《先驱报》的一位记者说，引述：我想作为母亲，我宁愿自己亲手杀死孩子们，早点结束这一切，也不愿让他们在一个坏人手下受折磨这么久。顺着博蒙特孩子们被恋童癖绑架的理论，《星期日邮报》刊登了一篇触及每个父母最深噩梦的故事。
With a headline declaring sex crime now feared, the article went one step further, stating that police suspected the three Beaumont children had been slain and voiced concerns that the Beaumont attacker could strike again. Parallels were drawn with the unsolved murders of 15-year-olds Mary Ann Schmidt and Christine Sharrock at Sydney's Wanda Beach the previous year, suggesting the same perpetrator could be responsible for both cases. The Wanda Beach and Beaumont cases shared noticeable similarities, as both involved children going missing from a crowded beach during the January school holidays.
头条新闻宣称现在担心发生性犯罪，这篇文章更进一步，声称警方怀疑这三个博蒙特孩子已经被杀害，并表达了对博蒙特袭击者可能会再次作案的担忧。人们将此案与前一年悉尼旺达海滩15岁少女玛丽·安·施密特和克里斯蒂娜·夏洛克未破的谋杀案进行了对比，暗示同一罪犯可能是这两起案件的幕后黑手。旺达海滩案和博蒙特案有着明显的相似之处，因为两起案件都涉及在一月份学校假期期间，儿童从拥挤的海滩上失踪。
But unlike the Wanda Beach case, where Mary Ann and Christine's bodies were found within a day of their disappearance near where they were last seen alive, no trace of the Beaumont children had surfaced in close to a week. By day five in the ongoing search for the Beaumont children, South Australian police had received over 1,000 phone calls in relation to the identity of their prime suspect. Further reports placed the Beaumont children on airplanes, in cars and at various locations throughout Adelaide. Interstate newspapers had also picked up on the story, leading to alleged sightings in other states as well. With the investigation now focusing on identifying the man last seen with the Beaumont children, police turned their attention to known sex offenders around the Haldfast Bay area.
但与旺达海滩案不同的是，玛丽·安和克里斯蒂娜的尸体在失踪后一天内就在他们生前最后一次被看到的附近被找到，而博蒙特孩子们的踪迹在将近一周的时间里都没有浮出水面。在搜寻博蒙特孩子的第五天，南澳大利亚警方已经收到了1000多个关于他们主要嫌疑人身份的电话。进一步的报告将博蒙特孩子放在了飞机上、汽车里以及阿德莱德各地的不同地点。州际报纸也报道了这个故事，导致其他州也据称发现了他们的踪迹。随着调查现在集中在确认最后一次与博蒙特孩子在一起的男人的身份，警方将注意力转向了哈尔德法斯特湾地区已知的性犯罪者。
As the suspect was seen by witnesses carrying only a towel and trousers, it was speculated he lived locally, as those visiting from further away would be inclined to come better prepared for the trip, possibly carrying a bag to hold their possessions. However, most known sexual predators who lived locally were able to provide solid alibis for the day the Beaumont children vanished. Detective Sergeant Alex Palmer urged the Glenelg residents to check their properties for any sign of the children. Quote, There are many vacant homes, both old ramshackle buildings in the old area of Glenelg and new houses in the nearby suburbs, and the children could have been lured into them, and anything could have happened.
由于目击者看到嫌疑人只携带了一条毛巾和裤子，人们推测他住在当地，因为从更远地方来的人往往会为行程做好更充分的准备，可能会带着一个袋子来装他们的财物。然而，大多数居住在当地的已知性侵犯都能为博蒙特孩子失踪的那一天提供不在场证明。侦探中士亚历克斯·帕尔默敦促格莱内格的居民检查他们的房产，看是否有任何孩子的迹象。引述：有许多空置的房屋，既有格莱内格老城区破旧的旧建筑，也有附近郊区的新房屋，孩子们可能被诱骗进这些房屋里，任何事情都可能发生。
Days turned into weeks and still there was no sign of Jane, Anna or Grant Beaumont. The South Australian state government put forward a modest reward sum of 500 pounds for any information about the whereabouts of the missing children. The reward was deemed highly inadequate, prompting local businessmen and private citizens to contribute to the amount in the hopes of encouraging others to follow suit. Jim Beaumont agreed to sell his house to boost the reward fund if anyone came forward with information leading to the safe return of his children. With donations from the local community, the reward grew to just over 10,000 pounds. This increased amount, coupled with the extensive media coverage of the case, led to an onslaught of false reports, hoaxes and wild theories about what happened to the children. People showed up unannounced on the Beaumont's doorstep to share their visions, psychic readings and extend their religious beliefs. Jim and Nancy listened patiently to everyone who reached out to them, but the constant media attention and wild speculations were taking their toll.
日子一天天过去，变成了几周，但简、阿尔娜或格兰特·博蒙特的踪迹依然全无。南澳大利亚州政府悬赏500英镑的微薄奖金，以征集有关失踪儿童下落的任何信息。这一悬赏被认为严重不足，促使当地商人和普通市民为这笔金额捐款，希望能鼓励其他人效仿。吉姆·博蒙特同意卖掉他的房子来增加悬赏金，前提是有人提供线索使他的孩子能够安全返回。在当地社区的捐款下，悬赏金额增长到了略多于10000英镑。这一增加的金额，加上对该案的大量媒体报道，导致了关于孩子们遭遇的虚假报告、恶作剧和疯狂理论的泛滥。人们不请自来地出现在博蒙特的门廊前，分享他们的幻觉、通灵读数，并表达他们的宗教信仰。吉姆和南希耐心地倾听了每一个联系他们的人，但源源不断的媒体关注和疯狂的猜测正在让他们付出沉重的代价。
Opportunistic strangers tried to take advantage of the grieving couple, while others added insult to injury by trying to point at the anguished parents as suspects. A man with a foreign accent called afternoon tabloid newspaper The News, claiming he was holding the Beaumont children for ransom. When the receptionist tried to connect the man with the editorial department, he hung up and was never heard from again. The call was quickly ruled a hoax, thought to be inspired by the kidnapping for ransom of Sydney schoolboy Graham Thorn six years earlier in 1960, which received huge nationwide media attention at the time. The kidnapping of Graham Thorn was covered in episode 75 of Case File. The federal police received a phone call from Adelaide resident Irwin Grosser, reporting that he had cited three children matching the descriptions of the missing Beaumont children. According to Grosser, the three children were being driven in a car by a lone man. Grosser alleged the man held him up with a pistol and demanded he fill his car radiator with water before fleeing with the children to the Barossa Valley, a renowned wine producing region 75 kilometers from Adelaide.
投机取巧的陌生人试图利用这对悲痛的夫妇，而另一些人则试图将痛苦的父母指为嫌疑人，这无异于雪上加霜。一个带有外国口音的男子打电话给下午的小报《新闻报》，声称他绑架了博蒙特的孩子并勒索赎金。当接待员试图将该男子转接给编辑部门时，他挂断了电话，从此再也没有人听到他的消息。这个电话很快被判定为恶作剧，被认为受到了六年前（即1960年）悉尼学童格雷厄姆·索恩因勒索赎金而遭绑架事件的启发，该事件当时在全国范围内受到了巨大的媒体关注。《罪案实录》第75集曾报道过格雷厄姆·索恩的绑架案。联邦警察接到阿德莱德居民欧文·格罗斯的电话，报告说他看到了三个符合失踪博蒙特儿童特征的孩子。据格罗斯称，这三个孩子正坐在一辆由一名孤身男子驾驶的汽车里。格罗斯称，该男子用手枪指着他，要求他给汽车水箱加满水，随后带着孩子逃往巴罗萨山谷，这是一个距离阿德莱德75公里的著名葡萄酒产区。
Later, Grosser admitted he had made this report while highly intoxicated and that it was based on nothing more than his own theory. He and a friend were prosecuted for making the false allegation. Following a report that the Beaumont children were being held captive by a man and woman at a home on Glenelgs Asplanade, the homicide squad raided several houses in the area, but found no trace of the children. The man who made the report admitted it was a lie, driven out of spite. The couple he had falsely reported as the Beaumont's captors were actually his estranged wife and her new boyfriend. After Melbourne based the newspaper The Truth published an ostentatious story declaring the Beaumont children to still be alive. Multiple witnesses claimed to have seen a man fitting the description of the prime suspect, driving a green Ford utility truck along the highway between Adelaide and Melbourne. The witnesses stated the man had two girls and a boy in the back. However, given the amount of time that had passed between the alleged sightings and the witness statements, police mostly discounted these sightings as unrelated to the case. The media speculated the perpetrator could have taken the Beaumont children as far as New Zealand, as no passports were required to travel between the two countries at the time.
后来，格罗斯承认他在高度醉酒的情况下做出了这份报告，这完全基于他自己的理论。他和一位朋友因作假供而受到起诉。在接到报告称博蒙特孩子们被一名男子和一名女子扣押在格莱内格滨海大道的一处住宅中后，凶杀组突击搜查了该地区的几所房屋，但没有发现孩子们的踪迹。那个做报告的男子承认这是一个出于怨恨而撒谎的谎言。他错误举报为博蒙特绑架者的一对男女实际上是他的分居妻子和她的新男友。在墨尔本报纸《真相》发表了一篇耸人听闻的报道，宣称博蒙特孩子们仍然活着之后，多名目击者声称看到一个符合主要嫌疑人特征的男子，驾驶着一辆绿色福特皮卡车在阿德莱德和墨尔本之间的高公路上行驶。目击者称，该男子的后车厢里有两个女孩和一个男孩。然而，鉴于所谓的目击事件与目击者陈述之间已经过去了一段时间，警方大多认为这些目击事件与案件无关，不予采信。媒体推测罪犯可能将博蒙特的孩子带到了新西兰，因为当时两国之间旅行不需要护照。
Pitches and descriptions of Jane, Arnor and Grant were sent to New Zealand authorities, with advice to remain on high alert. A Summerton Park resident reported seeing three children walking along Boundary Road, a residential suburban street with links to Moseley Street, shortly before 3pm on January 26. The children were in the company of a man, described as aged between 30 and 35, 6 feet tall, with light brown hair, high cheekbones and a sun-reddened complexion. He was carrying a dark airline-style bag and walked with a slight distinct swagger. As this description was inconsistent with the characteristics of the unknown man last seen with the Beaumont children, investigators mostly ruled this sighting out. After two weeks of searching had failed to uncover any signs of Jane, Arnor and Grant, Jim Beaumont hesitantly returned to work in an attempt to restore some semblance of normalcy to his life. Nancy joined her husband on the road, desperate for a distraction and a change of scenery, as every corner of their empty family home reminded her of their missing children. With leads reaching dead ends and a no-new information surfacing, stories of the Beaumont children's disappearance started to fade from the headlines.
简、阿尔娜和格兰特的照片和描述被发送给了新西兰当局，并建议保持高度戒备。一名萨默顿公园居民报告说，在1月26日下午3点前不久，看到三个孩子沿着边界路步行，这是一条与莫斯利街相连的住宅郊区街道。孩子们由一名男子陪同，据描述该男子年龄在30到35岁之间，身高6英尺，浅棕色头发，高颧骨，阳光晒红的肤色。他提着一个深色的航空风格包，走路时微微带着独特的摇摆姿态。由于这个描述与最后一次见到博蒙特孩子的未知男子的特征不一致，调查人员大体上排除了这次目击。在经历了两个星期的搜寻未能发现简、阿尔娜和格兰特的任何迹象后，吉姆·博蒙特犹豫不决地回到了工作岗位，试图让他的生活恢复某种形式的正常。南希加入了丈夫在路上的行列，迫切需要分散注意力并改变环境，因为他们空荡荡的家里的每一个角落都在提醒她失踪的孩子。随着线索陷入死胡同，没有新信息浮出水面，关于博蒙特孩子失踪的故事开始从头条新闻中淡出。
In an attempt to keep the story in the news, Jim and Nancy sporadically agreed to interviews with the press, but their discomfort in the spotlight was clear and the constant trauma of having to relive their ordeal caused the couple great distress. Without any new compelling information to report, the media attention and public assistance in their case began to dissipate. Australia's then leading forensic psychiatrist Dr. John McGeorge was interviewed by journalists looking for a fresh angle on the story. Dr. McGeorge had assessed many of Australia's worst criminals and his experience had earned him a shining reputation for correctly forecasting the outcome of criminal cases. Based on his experience and knowledge, he predicted all three Beaumont children were dead and their killer was a psychopath or someone with a borderline mental illness and perverted tendencies. Dr. McGeorge depicted the children's killer as a reserved person with limited intelligence and few friends, who likely lived in a boarding house or with elderly parents. By Easter 1966, Jim and Nancy Beaumont refused to give up hope that their children were alive. They kept their home perfectly intact, wanting to keep everything exactly as it had been the day the children left.
为了让这个故事保持在新闻中，吉姆和南希零星地同意接受媒体采访，但他们在聚光灯下的不适感显而易见，不断重温痛苦经历的创伤给这对夫妇带来了巨大的痛苦。由于没有任何引人注目的新信息可供报道，媒体的关注和公众对他们案件的援助开始消退。澳大利亚当时领先的法医精神病学家约翰·麦乔治博士接受了记者的采访，记者们希望从这个故事中找到一个新的切入点。麦乔治博士曾评估过澳大利亚许多最危险的罪犯，他的经验为他赢得了准确预测刑事案件结果的光辉声誉。基于他的经验和知识，他预测这三个博蒙特孩子都已经死了，他们的凶手是一个精神病患者或患有边缘性精神疾病和变态倾向的人。麦乔治博士将孩子们的凶手描述为一个性格内向、智力有限、朋友不多的内向之人，很可能住在寄宿公寓里或与年迈的父母同住。到1966年复活节，吉姆和南希·博蒙特拒绝放弃他们的孩子还活着的希望。他们将家保持得完好无缺，希望把一切都保持得和孩子们离开那天一模一样。
Everything from the backyard swing set to the kids' books, toys and bikes awaited their return. Even the girls' straw school hats hung expectantly on their usual hooks in the hallway. Through their despair, Jim and Nancy remained optimistic that their children had been abducted by someone who was keeping them alive and well. There had been reports throughout Australia of desperate childless couples attempting to kidnap children to raise as their own, so the prospect of the Beaumont children being alive wasn't completely without merit. Nancy Beaumont told a reporter, quote, They can't have just vanished off the face of the earth. Nobody can do that. We go over and over it between ourselves, and to the logical thing seems to be that someone has them. It could be a friend or someone we have never met.
从后院的秋千到孩子们的书、玩具和自行车，一切都在等待他们的归来。甚至女孩们的草帽也充满期待地挂在走廊里它们平时挂的钩子上。在绝望中，吉姆和南希仍然乐观地认为他们的孩子是被某个让他们活着并照顾得很好的人绑架了。澳大利亚各地一直有关于绝望的无子夫妇试图绑架儿童当作自己孩子抚养的报道，因此博蒙特孩子活着的可能性并非完全没有根据。南希·博蒙特告诉一位记者，引述：他们不可能就这样从地球表面凭空消失。没有人能做到这一点。我们在我们自己之间一遍又一番地讨论，合乎逻辑的事情似乎是有人藏匿了他们。这可能是一个朋友，或者是一个我们从未谋面的人。
If they had got into a stranger's car, it would only have been because the younger two children had talked Jane into it. September 1966 marked seven months since the Beaumont children vanished without a trace. On September 27, senior Constable Ron Gross was attempting to make a call to police headquarters in Melbourne from his police station in Connaiva, a small Victorian town 25 kilometres east of the South Australian border. As he waited for the call to connect, his line became crossed with a conversation occurring between two females. Senior Constable Gross heard one of the women say, We're bringing the Beaumont kids back from Hobart, and we are tired and think it's time to give up. Convinced the call was authentic, Gross reported the conversation to the Victorian Homicide Squad, who quickly notified South Australian authorities. Upon hearing news of the phone call, Jim and Nancy Beaumont thought it was the strongest lead there had been since their children's disappearance months prior, and quickly clung to hopes that the call was genuine.
如果他们上了陌生人的车，那也一定是因为较小的两个孩子说服了简这么做的。1966年9月标志着博蒙特孩子无影无踪地失踪已经七个月了。9月27日，资深警员罗恩·格罗斯正试图从他位于康纳伊瓦（位于南澳边界以东25公里的维多利亚州小镇）的警察局拨打电话给墨尔本的警察总部。在等待电话接通时，他的线路与两个女性之间的对话交叉了。资深警员格罗斯听到其中一个女人说：“我们正把博蒙特孩子们从霍巴特带回来，我们累了，觉得是时候放弃了。”确信这个电话是真的，格罗斯向维多利亚州凶杀组报告了这次对话，后者迅速通知了南澳大利亚当局。听到这个电话的消息时，吉姆和南希·博蒙特认为这是几个月前他们孩子失踪以来最强有力的线索，并迅速紧紧抓住了这个电话是真实的希望。
Jim Beaumont drove 320 kilometres to Connaiva to speak to senior Constable Ron Gross in person, and was told the exclusive brethren, a subset of the Christian evangelical movement, were active in the remote areas around Connaiva. This information sparked Jim's attention, as rumours had been circulating that a religious sect could be holding his children captive. Nancy Beaumont made a heartfelt plea on television news, quote, Please, whoever you are, please listen with your heart. I feel that in different ways you have been kind to our children, but I beg you, show a greater kindness by letting them come home. The suspicious call overheard by senior Constable Ron Gross was successfully traced a few days later. The two women on the other line were identified, and clarified to police they had been talking about the Beaumont case, before switching the conversation to an unrelated topic regarding some other children that they knew. Police were satisfied the women were being truthful and had nothing to do with the Beaumont case, quickly eliminating them from the investigation. 1966 was a big year for Australian news. Prime Minister Sir Robert Menzies retired after 17 years in the top office to be replaced by Harold Hull.
吉姆·博蒙特驱车320公里前往康纳伊瓦亲自与资深警员罗恩·格罗斯交谈，并被告知基督复临安息日会的一个分支——基督徒福音派运动的一个子集，在康纳伊瓦周围的偏远地区很活跃。这一信息引起了吉姆的注意，因为有传言称一个宗教教派可能将他的孩子扣为人质。南希·博蒙特在电视新闻上发出了一声深情的呼吁，引述：求求你们，无论你们是谁，请用你们的心去听。我觉得你们以不同的方式对我们的孩子们很好，但我恳求你们，让他们回家来展现更大的善意吧。几天后，资深警员罗恩·格罗斯无意中听到的可疑电话被成功追踪到了。电话那头的两个女人被确认了身份，并向警方澄清，她们在谈论博蒙特案件之前，把话题转到了关于她们认识的其他孩子的不相关话题上。警方对这些女性说的是实话且与博蒙特案件无关感到满意，并迅速将她们排除在调查之外。1966年对澳大利亚新闻来说是重要的一年。罗伯特·孟席斯爵士在担任最高职务17年后退休，由哈罗德·霍尔接任。
Australia made the move to the decimal currency system, with the Australian dollar replacing the pre-existing Australian pound. Japan replaced Great Britain as Australia's largest trading partner. An assassination attempt was taken out on Labor Party leader Arthur Caldwell. Entertainment and sporting venues were allowed to trade on Sundays for the first time. As these stories dominated national headlines and prime times, the unsolved case of the missing Beaumont children was vastly overshadowed. Something big needed to happen to prevent the case from fading into obscurity. Jim and Nancy Beaumont had already been approached by many self-proclaimed spiritualists who claimed to know the whereabouts of their children. One such spiritualist claimed to have received a vision of the children buried in a grave at the bottom of a cliff in the beachside suburb of Merino, nine kilometres south from Glenelk. His premonition promptly sparked a police search of the suspected site, but nothing was found. In a bid to help solve the mystery, an employee of South Australian newspaper, the advertiser, wrote a letter to famed Dutch clairvoyant Gerard Croyset, asking for his assistance to help locate the missing Beaumont children.
澳大利亚转向了十进位货币系统，澳大利亚元取代了原先的澳大利亚镑。日本取代英国成为澳大利亚最大的贸易伙伴。对工党领袖亚瑟·考德威尔进行了一次暗杀未遂。娱乐和体育场所历史上首次被允许在周日营业。随着这些故事主导了全国头条新闻和黄金时段，失踪博蒙特儿童的未破案件被大大掩盖了。需要发生一件大事来防止这个案件陷入默默无闻。吉姆和南希·博蒙特已经接触了许多自称是通灵者的人，他们声称知道他们孩子的下落。其中一个通灵者声称得到了一个幻象，看到孩子们被埋在海滨郊区梅里诺（位于格莱内格以南九公里）悬崖底部的坟墓里。他的预感迅速引发了警方对可疑地点的搜查，但什么也没找到。为了帮助解开这个谜团，南澳大利亚报纸《广告商报》的一名员工写信给著名的荷兰千里眼杰拉德·克罗泽特，请求他协助寻找失踪的博蒙特儿童。
Croyset, who claimed to have started receiving psychic visions during his adolescence, had earned a reputation in the Netherlands for assisting police in solving murders and missing person cases. His fame had spread throughout Europe and to the United States, and his help was sought in many high-profile criminal cases. From his home in Holland, Croyset responded to the newspaper employee's letter, stating he believed the Beaumont children had been involved in a tragic accident unrelated to foul play. He said they could have been playing innocently when something around them collapsed, causing them to lose a battle against sand or water. Croyset's visions revealed the children's bodies were lying on a stretch of open land not too far from the sea, about half a mile from where they were last seen. He requested to be sent photographs of Glenelk and its surrounds in order to determine exactly where the Beaumont children were located. Croyset's interest in the Beaumont children was the fresh scoop needed to bring the case back into the media spotlight. Word of Croyset's vision was quickly published by the advertiser, with several other publications reaching out to the Dutch psychic and printing their own take on the story.
声称在青春期开始收到通灵幻象的克罗泽特，在荷兰因协助警方侦破谋杀和失踪人员案件而赢得了声誉。他的名气传遍了整个欧洲和美国，他的帮助在许多备受瞩目的刑事案件中被寻求。从他在荷兰的家中，克罗泽特回信给这位报社员工，称他认为博蒙特孩子们卷入了一起与谋杀无关的悲剧事故。他说他们可能在无辜地玩耍时，周围的某个东西坍塌了，导致他们没能战胜沙子或水。克罗泽特的幻象显示孩子们的尸体躺在一片离海不远的开阔地上，距离他们最后一次被看到的地方大约半英里。他请求将格莱内格及其周边的照片寄给他，以便准确确定博蒙特孩子们的位置。克罗泽特对博蒙特孩子的兴趣正是将案件重新带回聚光灯下所需的新鲜独家新闻。克罗泽特幻象的消息很快被《广告商报》发表，其他几家出版物也联系了这位荷兰通灵者并刊登了他们对这个故事的看法。
The new media attention renewed public interest, with many members of the public flocking to caves and hollows throughout Glenelk and neighbouring coastal areas to search for Jane, Arnor and Grant, based purely on Croyset's word. Upon receipt of photographs and further information, Croyset's visions became more vivid. He described seeing the three children's bodies lying in a cave near rocks on the beach, with scrub land and a square house to the right-hand side, and a shoals or a coral reef in the distance. South Australian citizens believed Gerard Croyset had identified the Minder Home in Brighton, a residential support and education facility for the intellectually disabled. Minder Home was located on the coast, three kilometres south from the Beaumont's property. The media quickly entertained theories that the perpetrator could have been a patient at Minder Home, who, after kidnapping and killing the Beaumont children, buried them on the foreshore in front of the Minder grounds. From his home in Holland, Croyset advised Adelaide citizens they were on the right track and encouraged them to keep digging. Front-end loaders were brought into Minder's coastal boundary to remove tonnes of sand and soil, but the excavation revealed nothing, and the dig became a public embarrassment.
新的媒体关注重新点燃了公众的兴趣，许多公众蜂拥至格莱内格及邻近沿海地区的洞穴和洼地，纯粹基于克罗泽特的话寻找简、阿尔娜和格兰特。在收到照片和进一步的信息后，克罗泽特的幻象变得更加生动。他描述看到三个孩子的尸体躺在海滩岩石附近的一个洞穴里，右侧有灌木丛和一栋方形房子，远处有浅滩或珊瑚礁。南澳大利亚市民认为杰拉德·克罗泽特已经确定了布赖顿的明达之家，这是一个为智力障残人士提供居住支持和教育的设施。明达之家位于海岸边，距离博蒙特家以南三公里。媒体迅速接受了这样的理论：罪犯可能是明达之家的病人，他在绑架并杀死博蒙特孩子们之后，将他们埋在了明达场地前面的前滨里。从他在荷兰的家中，克罗泽特建议阿德莱德市民他们走对了路，并鼓励他们继续挖掘。前置装载机被带到明达的海岸边界以清除数吨的沙子和土壤，但挖掘没有发现任何东西，这次挖掘成了一场公众尴尬。
In November 1966, two prominent Adelaide businessmen funded a trip to bring psychic Gerard Croyset to Australia. Ten months had passed since the disappearance of the Beaumont children, and it was believed that Croyset's physical presence in the key locations from where they had vanished would strengthen his psychic abilities and help lead authorities to Jane, Anna and Grant. One donor was Barry Blackwell of Brighton car company Midway Motors, who had already made several generous contributions to the Beaumont investigation, including a significant boost to the reward money. The other donor was Con Polides, a self-made Adelaide property tycoon who relished being in the limelight. Given the amount of contact Jim and Nancy Beaumont had received from self-proclaimed psychics, the couple were skeptical about Croyset's claims and were not actively involved in the efforts to bring the clairvoyant to Australia. Gerard Croyset agreed to stay in Adelaide for two days and refused any payment for his involvement in the case. He was conducting his search for the Beaumont children in good faith, claiming he was 90% sure he would be able to pinpoint the location of their bodies. His arrival in Adelaide prompted a media frenzy that outshone the arrival of British rock and roll band The Beatles two years earlier.
1966年11月，两位杰出的阿德莱德商人资助了一次行程，将通灵者杰拉德·克罗泽特带到澳大利亚。距离博蒙特孩子们失踪已经过去了十个月，人们相信克罗泽特亲自出现在他们消失的关键地点将增强他的通灵能力，并有助于引导当局找到简、阿尔娜和格兰特。其中一位捐赠者是布赖顿汽车公司中途汽车的巴里·布莱克韦尔，他已经为博蒙特调查做出了几次慷慨的贡献，包括大幅增加悬赏金。另一位捐赠者是康·波利德斯，一个自学成才的阿德莱德房地产大亨，他很享受成为人们关注的焦点。鉴于吉姆和南希·博蒙特收到了来自自称通灵者的许多联系，这对夫妇对克罗泽特的说法持怀疑态度，没有积极参与将这位千里眼带到澳大利亚的努力。杰拉德·克罗泽特同意在阿德莱德呆两天，并拒绝为他参与此案支付任何报酬。他是出于善意寻找博蒙特孩子的，声称他有90%的把握能够准确定位他们尸体的位置。他的到来在阿德莱德引发了一场媒体狂热，甚至盖过了两年前英国摇滚乐队披头士到来的风头。
A crowd of 2,000 people greeted Croyset at Adelaide Airport, including 30 reporters and cameramen, with the anticipation running high that he would finally solve the mystery that had been haunting residents for close to a year. Croyset was overwhelmed by the reception, saying all he wanted to do was help solve the tragedy and release the city from fear. The next morning, Croyset visited Coley Reserve, where it was believed Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont were last seen. He then walked three kilometres along the Glenelgue foreshore with a media crew following close behind. Later, Croyset was driven through the streets of Glenelgue and passed the Minda Home, which Adelaide residents had pinpointed as the location he had envisioned in previous psychic visions. Despite previous large-scale digs of the area proving fruitless, upon his arrival to the area, Croyset claimed he was now very close to finding the children. The next day, he searched vacant blocks of land without uncovering any evidence, before complaining that too many people were following him and all the attention was weakening his psychic abilities. On his final morning in Adelaide, Gerard Croyset held an impromptu press conference to reveal that new information had since come to light overnight.
2000名群众在阿德莱德机场迎接克罗泽特，其中包括30名记者和摄像师，人们满怀期待他最终能解开这个困扰居民将近一年的谜团。克罗泽特被这种盛况吓坏了，说他只想帮助解决这场悲剧，让这座城市摆脱恐惧。第二天早上，克罗泽特参观了科利保护区，人们认为简、阿尔娜和格兰特·博蒙特最后就是在那里被看到的。然后他沿着格莱内格前滨步行了三公里，后面紧跟着一个媒体团队。后来，克罗泽特坐车穿过格莱内格的街道，经过了明达之家，阿德莱德居民已经指出这是他在之前的通灵幻象中设想的位置。尽管该地区以前的大规模挖掘证明毫无结果，但在他抵达该地区后，克罗泽特声称他现在离找到孩子们非常近。第二天，他在没有发现任何证据的情况下搜寻了空置的土地，然后抱怨太多人跟着他，所有的注意力都在削弱他的通灵能力。在他留在阿德莱德的最后一天早上，杰拉德·克罗泽特举行了一场即兴新闻发布会，透露隔夜有新信息浮出水面。
A woman claimed she had heard children's voices in a disused warehouse near her home in the early morning hours of January 27, 1966. The night the Beaumont children went missing. At the time, the warehouse was vacant, having previously been used for brickworks. It had since been converted into a joinery company, and although extensive renovations of the building had been conducted in August, it was possible that several underground chutes leading to the old brick kiln still existed. Croyset led police and members of the press to a warehouse on Wilton Avenue in Paringa Park, less than 500 meters from the Beaumont's home, believing the children were buried 2 to 3 meters deep in an underground bunker. He walked to the northern wall of the warehouse and said, this is where they are buried. According to his visions, Gerard Croyset claimed the Beaumont children were afraid to go home in the dark, so they huddled for shelter near the empty warehouse. The trio were standing on planks of wood, which then caved in, causing them to fall underground. The floor of the warehouse had since been concreted, meaning the children's bodies were entombed underneath.
一个女人声称她在1966年1月27日清晨听到她家附近一个废弃仓库里有孩子的声音。那是博蒙特孩子们失踪的那个晚上。当时，仓库是空置的，以前曾用于砖厂。后来它被改造成了一家细木工公司，尽管8月份对该建筑进行了大规模的装修，但通往旧砖窑的几个地下滑槽可能仍然存在。克罗泽特带领警察和媒体成员来到帕林加公园威尔顿大道的一个仓库，距离博蒙特家不到500米，相信孩子们被埋在地下地堡2到3米深处。他走到仓库的北墙说：“这就是他们被埋的地方。”根据他的幻象，杰拉德·克罗泽特声称博蒙特孩子们害怕在黑暗中回家，所以他们挤在空仓库附近避难。三个人站在木板上，木板随后坍塌，导致他们掉入地下。仓库的地板后来被浇筑了混凝土，这意味着孩子们的尸体被埋在地下。
After bestowing this information, Gerard Croyset supported the idea of excavating the concrete floor, and then promptly left the country. Residents of Adelaide took Croyset's word as gospel, believing he had uncovered the final resting place of Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont. Under pressure from the public, the South Australian government deliberated whether to dig up the warehouse's concrete floor using taxpayer money, based on nothing more than a psychic premonition. Although Jim and Nancy Beaumont had met with Croyset briefly during his visit, and appreciated his interest in the case, they were not convinced of his psychic abilities, and did not support the dig. Police investigated Croyset's claims by researching what the conditions of the old warehouse were like in January of 1966, and determined there was nothing plausible about Croyset's so-called vision. The building owners assured police all in-ground pits were thoroughly inspected before concreting work began, and there were no signs indicating the children had fallen into any. In late November 1966, South Australian Premier Frank Walsh stated, quote, Investigations have shown conclusively, without a shadow of a doubt, that there is no possible chance the factory is the burial ground of the missing children.
在赋予这些信息后，杰拉德·克罗泽特支持挖掘混凝土底板的想法，然后迅速离开了这个国家。阿德莱德居民将克罗泽特的话视为金科玉律，相信他已经发现了简、阿尔娜和格兰特·博蒙特的最终安息之地。在公众的压力下，南澳大利亚政府权衡是否仅凭通灵预感用纳税人的钱挖开仓库的混凝土底板。虽然吉姆和南希·博蒙特在克罗泽特访问期间与他进行了短暂会面，并赞赏他对案件的兴趣，但他们并不相信他的通灵能力，也没有支持这次挖掘。警方通过研究1966年1月旧仓库的状况来调查克罗泽特的说法，并确定克罗泽特所谓的幻象没有任何合理性。建筑业主向警方保证，在开始混凝土浇筑工作之前，所有地下坑都经过了彻底检查，没有迹象表明孩子们掉进去了。1966年11月下旬，南澳大利亚州长弗兰克·沃尔什表示，引述：调查已经确凿无误地表明，这家工厂完全不可能是失踪儿童的埋葬地。
It was decided that an excavation of the concrete flooring would not go ahead. However, the public wasn't convinced of the findings, and were certain Croyset's visions were correct. A Citizen Action Committee banded together to conduct a public survey in support of the excavation, and raised $7,000 to fund the project. The excavation took place the following year, in March 1967. Workers demolished 60 feet of the concrete flooring, revealing an old staircase, a brick kiln, a piece of cloth, lolly wrappers, lemon peel, and newspapers, none of which were found to have had any relevance to the Beaumont case. The remains of Jane, Anna and Grant were not discovered. On behalf of the South Australian Government, Premier Frank Walsh apologised to Jim and Nancy Beaumont for the continued anxiety and sorrow. By the one year anniversary of the Beaumont Children's disappearance, their parents were still clinging to the belief that Jane, Anna and Grant were alive, as it was the only thing giving them the energy to carry on.
决定不对混凝土底板进行挖掘。然而，公众并不相信这些调查结果，确信克罗泽特的幻象是正确的。公民行动委员会联合起来进行了一项支持挖掘的公众调查，并筹集了7000美元来资助这个项目。挖掘工作在第二年（1967年3月）进行。工人们拆除了60英尺的混凝土底板，露出一座旧楼梯、一座砖窑、一块布、糖果包装纸、柠檬皮和报纸，经发现这些都与博蒙特案没有任何关系。没有发现简、阿尔娜和格兰特的遗骸。代表南澳大利亚政府，州长弗兰克·沃尔什就持续的焦虑和悲伤向吉姆和南希·博蒙特道歉。到博蒙特孩子失踪一周年之际，他们的父母仍然坚信简、阿尔娜和格兰特还活着，因为这是唯一给他们坚持下去的精力的东西。
Jim Beaumont continued to grasp under his theory that the children were lured and abducted. A man or woman, or probably a man and a woman together, persuaded them to get into a car and drove them away somewhere. They might have told them Nancy and I were killed in an accident, and that they've got them somewhere. It would have to be a station, or some isolated place like that. My God, if they could only see what it's doing to Nancy and me, it's no good without the children, not when you have had them. I just can't understand life without my kids. There's no point to it. Despite Jim and Nancy Beaumont's continued hope their children would be returned to them alive, by the two year anniversary of the disappearance, investigators were no closer to uncovering the mystery. Emotionally exhausted, Jim and Nancy decided to take a step back from the media spotlight after providing one last in-depth interview.
吉姆·博蒙特继续坚持他的理论，即孩子们被诱骗和绑架了。一个男人或女人，或者可能是一个男人和一个女人在一起，说服他们上了一辆车，把他们带到了某个地方。他们可能告诉他们南希和我在一次事故中丧生了，他们把他们带到了某个地方。那一定是一个车站，或者像那样偏远的地方。天哪，如果他们能看到这对南希和我是多么残酷，没有孩子们的生活是没有意义的，特别是当你曾拥有过他们的时候。我简直无法理解没有我的孩子的生活。这毫无意义。尽管吉姆和南希·博蒙特一直希望他们的孩子能活着回到他们身边，但到了失踪两周年之际，调查人员离揭开这个谜团并没有更近一步。精疲力竭的吉姆和南希在进行了一次最后深入的采访后，决定从聚光灯下退一步。
They spoke to the press in detail about Jane, Anna and Grant, and what they missed most about the well-behaved, sweet-natured children they had always dreamed of having, whilst thanking the South Australian police for their tireless work, and praising the community for all the ongoing support. The heartfelt interview ended with Nancy Beaumont's response to the question of whether she and Jim would relocate to a new home for a fresh start. Nancy said, quote, I can't go in case the kiddies come home. You see, I'm waiting for them to come back here. Perhaps someone could drop them at the front gate. Wouldn't it be dreadful if I were not here? In the days following this interview, Jim and Nancy Beaumont were shaken when a letter arrived to their home signed by their missing daughter Jane. Written in child-like handwriting, the letter read, When a man in a car stopped us and asked if we wanted a ride, I said that we did, and that is how it all started. The man would not let us ride before. He is letting us ride now because he saw the article in the Herald tonight, and felt sorry for you both. He watched us a lot for about six weeks, and then he did not watch us so much. Anna and I often talk about you, but Grant does not remember you at all after more than two years. We have been fed well all the time.
他们向媒体详细讲述了简、阿尔娜和格兰特，以及他们最怀念那些他们一直梦想拥有的、表现良好且心地善良的孩子们的什么，同时感谢南澳大利亚警方的辛勤工作，并赞扬社区给予的所有持续支持。这段感人至深的采访以南希·博蒙特对她和吉姆是否会搬到一个新家重新开始的问题的回答而结束。南希说，引述：我不能走，万一孩子们回家了呢。你看，我在等他们回到这里。也许有人会把他们放在前门。如果我不在那里，那该多可怕啊。在这篇采访之后的几天里，当一封信寄到他们家并由他们失踪的女儿简签名时，吉姆和南希·博蒙特被震惊了。这封信是用孩子般的手写体写的，上面写着：当一个车里的男人停下来问我们是否想搭车时，我说我们想，这就是这一切开始的原因。那个人之前不让我们搭车。他现在让我们搭车是因为他看到了今晚《先驱报》上的文章，并且对你们两个感到抱歉。他监视了我们大约六周，然后他就不那么经常监视我们了。阿尔娜和我经常谈论你，但在两年多后，格兰特根本记不起你了。我们一直被喂得很好。
I, as well as Anna and Grant, hope that you are both well. The man said to me just now that he will willingly let us go if you will come over to Victoria to get us, as long as you do not call the police. In the letter, Jane went on to request that her father come to Dandenong to meet their captor, a southeastern suburb in the neighbouring state of Victoria, 760km away from Beaumont's home. The rendezvous was scheduled to take place at the front of Dandenong's local post office at 8.50am the following Monday, February 26. Jane instructed her father to wear a dark coat and white pants, ensuring he would be easily identifiable to their captor. She stressed that it was very important that the police must not be informed. Jim and Nancy Beaumont believed the handwriting in the letter bore similarities to that of Jane's and felt it possible the letter was indeed written by their oldest daughter. Their major concern was that Anna's name had been misspelled in the letter, using only one N instead of two, despite the fact that Jane knew the correct spelling of her sister's name. Not wanting to disregard the letter on what could have been a simple spelling mistake, Jim and Nancy contacted the head of the South Australian Homicide Squad, Detective Sergeant Stan Swain, and talked him into helping them organise a secret trip to Dandenong. Swain agreed and put the plans in place, keeping his involvement strictly confidential as to not alert the alleged captor to the involvement of law enforcement.
我和阿尔娜以及格兰特都希望你们两个都好。那个人刚才对我说，只要你们不去报警，如果你们愿意去维多利亚接我们，他会心甘情愿地让我们走。在这封信中，简接着要求她的父亲去丹德农见他们的绑架者，这是邻近维多利亚州的一个东南部郊区，距离博蒙特家760公里。约会预定在下周一（2月6日）上午8点50分在丹德农当地邮局前进行。简指示她的父亲穿一件深色外套和白色裤子，确保绑架者能轻易认出他。她强调绝对不能通知警察，这一点非常重要。吉姆和南希·博蒙特认为这封信中的笔迹与简的笔迹有相似之处，并觉得这封信确实可能是由他们的大女儿写的。他们最大的担忧是信中阿尔娜的名字拼写错了，只用了一个N而不是两个，尽管简知道她妹妹名字的正确拼写。不想因为一个可能是简单拼写错误而忽视这封信，吉姆和南希联系了南澳大利亚凶杀组负责人侦探中士斯坦·斯温，并说服他帮助他们组织了一次去丹德农的秘密行程。斯温同意并制定了计划，对他的参与严格保密，以免惊动所谓的绑架者执法部门的参与。
Prior to his arrival to Dandenong, Swain called ahead and booked a room at a local hotel where he would stay for the duration of the scheduled meet-up. When making the booking, the Detective Sergeant gave the hotel manager his full name. As there had been some thefts in the Dandenong area recently, the owner of the hotel was wary about letting a complete stranger stay in his establishment. To make sure this guest didn't present a threat, he contacted a local police officer to run a background check on the name Stan Swain. The local officer discovered it belonged to a South Australian Homicide Squad detective who was heavily involved in the Beaumont case. Instead of treating this information sensitively, the officer then called a reporter at the Melbourne-based Herald newspaper to advise him of Detective Swain's surprise appearance in town. The Herald newspaper sent a group of reporters and photographers to the Dandenong region to discreetly scope out Detective Swain's whereabouts, convinced his presence had something to do with the Beaumont case. At the same time, the news newspaper in Adelaide had received a tip-off from someone close to the Beaumont family and sent their own group of reporters and photographers interstate to investigate.
在抵达丹德农之前，斯温提前打电话在当地一家酒店预订了一个房间，他将在那里度过预定的会面时间。在预订时，这位侦探警长向酒店经理提供了他的全名。由于丹德农地区最近发生了一些盗窃案，酒店老板对让一个完全陌生的人入住他的酒店心存戒备。为了确保这位客人不构成威胁，他联系了一名当地警官，对斯坦·斯温这个名字进行背景调查。当地警官发现，这个名字属于南澳大利亚凶杀案调查组的一名侦探，他深度参与了博蒙特案。该警官没有对这些信息进行敏感处理，而是打电话给总部设在墨尔本的《先驱报》的一名记者，向他通报了斯温侦探突然现身镇上的消息。《先驱报》派遣了一组记者和摄影师前往丹德农地区，秘密搜寻斯温侦探的下落，确信他的出现与博蒙特案有关。与此同时，阿德莱德的新闻报纸也收到了来自博蒙特家族亲近之人的线索，并派出了自己的记者和摄影师跨州进行调查。
On the morning of Monday, February 26, Jim Beaumont stood alone out the front of the Dandenong Post Office as he'd been instructed to do in the letter from Jane. Detective Sergeant Stan Swain was watching discreetly from nearby, posing as a window cleaner. The telephone rang inside the Dandenong Post Office, and the mail caller asked the staff member to inform Jim Beaumont that he was running late, but would be at their designated meeting spot as soon as possible. Throughout the day, other nearby businesses received calls from the unknown mail, who instructed employees to relay further messages to Jim. The mysterious man maintained he was still on his way. Desperate to believe he would be reunited with his children at long last, Jim Beaumont stood in front of the Dandenong Post Office for three days. However, there were no signs of Jane, Anna, Grant, or the mysterious man. Dejected, Jim and Nancy returned to Adelaide, where two more letters were awaiting them upon their arrival.
在2月26日星期一的早晨，吉姆·博蒙特独自站在丹德农邮局前，正如简的信中所指示的那样。侦探警长斯坦·斯温在附近秘密观察，伪装成擦窗工。丹德农邮局内的电话铃响了，寄信人要求工作人员通知吉姆·博蒙特，他快迟到了，但会尽快赶到指定的会面地点。在这一天里，附近的其他企业也接到了神秘寄信人的电话，要求员工向吉姆转达进一步的信息。这个神秘男子坚信自己仍在路上。吉姆·博蒙特渴望相信自己终于能与孩子们团聚，他在丹德农邮局门前站了三天。然而，没有任何关于简、安娜、格兰特或这个神秘男子的迹象。沮丧的吉姆和南希回到了阿德莱德，他们到达时，还有另外两封信在等着他们。
One letter was allegedly from Jane, who said their captor was very disappointed that they brought the police with them to Dandenong. The second letter claimed to be from the captor himself. He wrote, Dear Mr and Mrs Beaumont, I am terribly sorry that I could not hand your children back to you when you were in Dandenong, but I knew you had detectives with you and the main street was so busy. I am taking extra good care of the kiddies for you. The writer went on to blame the Beaumonts for going against his wishes and informing the police. He said it was too late now, and that one day, in the near future, he would put their children on a train to Adelaide, so they better have their bedrooms ready for their arrival. The following week, a third letter arrived from Jane, this one saying,
其中一封信据称来自简，信中说他们的绑架者对他们把警察带到丹德农感到非常失望。第二封信声称来自绑架者本人。他写道：亲爱的博蒙特先生和太太，非常抱歉当你们在丹德农时我无法把孩子们还给你们，但我知道你们有侦探陪同，而且主街太拥挤了。我会替你们把孩子们照顾得格外好。信接着指责博蒙特夫妇违背了他的意愿并通知了警察总局。他说现在已经太晚了，总有一天，在不久的将来，他会把他们的孩子们送上一列开往阿德莱德的火车，所以他们最好为孩子们的到来准备好卧室。第二周，简寄来了第三封信，信上说：
I want you to know and never forget, no matter what happens, that we will still love you both very much. The 60s came to an end without any major breakthroughs or new leads in the case of the missing Beaumont children, and if there were no further letters sent from the person claiming to be Jane Beaumont, or the man alleging to be holding the children captive. The constant trauma and heartbreak endured by Nancy and Jim Beaumont led to their eventual divorce, although they maintained a valued friendship thereafter. They both moved away from the family home on Harding Street in Summerton Park, leaving behind the crushing hopes that their smiling children would one day swing open the gate and walk inside. With the media now firmly focused on the Vietnam War, the disappearance of 9-year-old Jane, 7-year-old Anna, and 4-year-old Grant became a distant memory. What was once the biggest criminal investigation in South Australia was now overseen by a single detective. Over the years, the occasional piece of information related to the case filtered through, and police continued to follow up on all lines of inquiry, no matter how speculative, but nothing substantial ever surfaced. 7 years after they vanished, memories of the Beaumont children's disappearance flooded back into the Adelaide consciousness as news of a similar abduction made headlines.
我想让你们知道并且永远不要忘记，无论发生什么，我们依然非常爱你们彼此。20世纪60年代在失踪的博蒙特儿童案中没有取得任何重大突破或新的线索中结束了，也没有再收到任何自称是简·博蒙特或声称扣押了这些孩子的男子的信件。南希和吉姆·博蒙特所承受的持续创伤和心碎导致了他们最终的离婚，尽管此后他们保持了宝贵的友谊。他们都搬离了位于萨默顿公园哈丁街的家庭住宅，留下了那些破碎的希望，即他们微笑着的孩子们有一天会推开大门走进来。随着媒体现在坚定地将焦点转向越南战争，9岁的简、7岁的安娜和4岁的格兰特的失踪成了遥远的记忆。曾经是南澳大利亚最大的刑事调查现在由一名侦探负责。多年来，偶尔会有与该案相关的零星信息流传出来，警察继续跟进所有的调查线索，无论它们多么具推测性，但从未浮现出任何实质性的内容。在他们失踪7年后，随着一起类似绑架案登上头条，关于博蒙特儿童失踪的记忆重新涌入阿德莱德公众的意识中。
On August 25, 1973, 11-year-old Joanne Ratcliffe escorted 4-year-old Kirsty Gordon to the bathroom stores during a football match held at Adelaide Oval. A large football and cricket stadium on the banks of the Torrens River, less than 2km north of the CBD. The trip should have taken just a few minutes, but 20 minutes later, the girls still hadn't returned to their families. The alarm was quickly raised and police were contacted, promptly initiating a full investigation. Joanne and Kirsty were last seen by several witnesses struggling with a man who then dragged the girls out of the Oval's southern gates. The man was described as being of average height, with a stooped posture, wearing a wide-brimmed Akubra-style hat, horn-rimmed glasses, grey-checkered sports jacket, and brown trousers. Investigators had learned a lot since the Beaumont case, and to now knew missing children cases should no longer be handled conservatively. This time, abduction and probable murder were suspected almost immediately, and reported in the media as such.
1973年8月25日，11岁的乔安妮·拉特克利夫在阿德莱德椭圆形球场举行的一场足球比赛期间，陪同4岁的基尔斯滕·戈登去洗手间。这是一个大型足球和板球场，位于托伦斯河岸边，在中央商务区以北不到2公里处。这趟行程本该只需几分钟，但20分钟后，女孩们仍未回到家人身边。警报迅速拉响，警方随即介入，并迅速展开全面调查。多名目击者最后看到乔安妮和基尔斯滕时，她们正在与一名男子拉扯，该男子随后将女孩们拖出了椭圆形球场的南门。据描述，该男子中等身材，有些驼背，头戴宽边阿库布拉式帽子，戴着黑框眼镜，身穿灰色格子运动夹克和棕色裤子。自博蒙特案以来，调查人员学到了很多，现在他们知道失踪儿童案件不应该再以保守的方式处理。这一次，几乎立即怀疑是绑架和可能的谋杀，并在媒体上进行了如此报道。
Yet, despite efforts, Joanne Ratcliffe and Kirsty Gordon were not located, nor was the man last seen with them identified. The investigation into finding Joanne and Kirsty played out similarly to the Beaumont case, in that no evidence was uncovered, and the subsequent search was bogged down by bogus sightings, wild speculations, hoaxes, and unsubstantiated visions from spiritualists, including input from Gerard Crozet, the Dutch clairvoyant whose psychic visions failed to uncover any sign of the Beaumont children. Based on witness accounts, a watercolour sketch of the man seen abducting Joanne and Kirsty was drawn up and widely circulated. Similarities were immediately drawn to the sketch of the unknown man seen in Coley Reserve with the Beaumont children just before they vanished in 1966. Both sketches depicted a middle-aged man with a long, lean face, and well-defined bone structure. Peter Alexander from the Police Association of South Australia later said, quote,
然而，尽管付出了努力，乔安妮·拉特克利夫和基尔斯滕·戈登仍未被找到，最后与她们在一起的男子也没有被识别。对寻找乔安妮和基尔斯滕的调查与博蒙特案相似，没有发现任何证据，随后的搜寻也被虚假的目击、疯狂的猜测、恶作剧以及灵媒毫无根据的幻觉所拖累，其中包括来自荷兰克莱尔沃扬特 Gerard Crozet 的意见，他的通灵幻觉未能发现博蒙特儿童的任何迹象。根据目击者的描述，绘制了一幅据信绑架了乔安妮和基尔斯滕的男子的水彩素描，并广泛分发。人们立即将其与1966年失踪前不久在科利保护区与博蒙特儿童一起被看到的未知男子的素描进行了相似性比较。两幅素描都描绘了一名中年男子，有着长而瘦的脸和清晰的骨骼结构。南澳大利亚警察协会的彼得·亚历山大后来引用了一句话：
There is a big chance these two crimes are linked. This type of offender, this type of killer, you just can't get a handle on. Even on a worldwide basis, these are extraordinary crimes. The psychology and supreme confidence of the guy is astounding. One group of children taken from a crowded beach, the other from a crowded sporting field, both in broad daylight. By the late 1970s and early 80s, South Australia was once again struck by a spade of horrific abductions and murders. Five young men went missing over those years, their bodies later found in various locations throughout Adelaide. Police believed a network of sadistic pedophiles were responsible for the crimes, men who held prominent positions within Adelaide society. As the perpetrators were suspected to go to great lengths to prevent one another from being detected, the brutal slayings were dubbed the family murders. In November 1984, Adelaide accountant Bevan Spencer Von Einem was sentenced to life in prison for the murder of 15-year-old Richard Kelvin, the fifth family murders victim.
这两起罪行有很大可能是有关联的。这类罪犯，这类杀手，你根本无法琢磨。即使在全球范围内，这也是非同寻常的罪行。这个家伙的心理和无上的自信令人震惊。一群孩子从拥挤的海滩被带走，另一群从拥挤的运动场被带走，两起事件都在光天化日之下发生。到了20世纪70年代末和80年代初，南澳大利亚再次遭遇了一连串可怕的绑架和谋杀案。在这几年里，五名年轻男子失踪，他们的尸体后来在阿德莱德各地的不同地点被发现。警方认为，一个虐待狂恋童癖网络是这些罪行的幕后黑手，这些男子在阿德莱德社会中占据显赫地位。由于怀疑犯罪分子会竭尽全力防止彼此被发现，这些残忍的谋杀案被称为家庭谋杀案。1984年11月，阿德莱德会计师贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆因谋杀15岁的理查德·凯尔文（家庭谋杀案的第五名受害者）而被判处终身监禁。
In 1990, the details of the committal hearing held prior to Bevan Spencer Von Einem's murder trial were released to the media after a series of suppression orders were lifted. A crown witness identified only as Mr. Be who had previously partnered with Von Einem in drugging and assaulting male hitchhikers had testified at the hearing. Mr. Be told the court that Von Einem had confessed to committing at least 10 murders, including the deaths of the Beaumont children. Von Einem had admitted to abducting the Beaumont children before connecting them up and performing some, quote, brilliant surgery on them. After one of the children died, he killed the other two and dumped the bodies at either Maiponga or Moana, two areas located on the southern coast of Adelaide. Von Einem also mentioned that he had picked up two children at the football, as in the case of Joey and Ratcliffe and Kirsty Gordon. Despite these alleged confessions, many aspects spotlighting Bevan Spencer Von Einem as a suspect in the Beaumont case didn't add up. Although his build matched that of the man last seen with the Beaumont children, Von Einem had only been 20 years old at the time of their disappearance.
1990年，在解除了多项禁止报道令后，媒体公开了在贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆谋杀案审判前举行的预审听证会的细节。一位仅被称为Be先生的皇家证人曾在听证会上作证，他此前曾与冯·艾内姆搭档，给男性搭便车者下药并进行攻击。Be先生告诉法庭，冯·艾内姆曾承认犯下至少10起谋杀案，包括博蒙特儿童的死亡。冯·艾内姆承认在绑架博蒙特儿童后，将他们连接起来并对他们进行了某些，引用原话，“精彩的手术”。其中一名孩子死后，他杀害了另外两人，并将尸体抛在迈庞加或莫阿纳，这两个地区位于阿德莱德南部海岸。冯·艾内姆还提到他在足球比赛中接走了两个孩子，就像乔伊·拉特克利夫和基尔斯滕·戈登的案件一样。尽管有这些所谓的供词，但许多将贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆作为博蒙特案嫌疑人的焦点并不吻合。尽管他的体型与最后一次被看到与博蒙特儿童在一起的男子相符，但冯·艾内姆在他们失踪时只有20岁。
This was much younger than witness descriptions, who consistently reported the man last seen with the children as being middle-aged in his 30s or early 40s. The Beaumont children also didn't fit the profile of Von Einem's preferred victims, who were typically males in their teens and early 20s. Bevan Spencer Von Einem denied any involvement in the abductions of the Beaumont children or Joey and Ratcliffe and Kirsty Gordon. However, speculation of his involvement in the Beaumont children's disappearance was reignited, when reports later circulated that a male spectator resembling a young Von Einem was caught in the background of archived news footage, watching as police divers searched the Padawalonga Boathaven. As killers have been known to return to the scene of their crime to either relive their fantasies or check on police progress, it was speculated that Von Einem was exhibiting textbook criminal behaviour. An expert in forensic facial mapping compared the images of the spectator to that of a young Von Einem and concluded there were considerable differences between the pair's facial structures. The Von Einem lookalike was determined to be just that. A lookalike. Nevertheless, Bevan Spencer Von Einem was not ruled out as a suspect in the Beaumont case.
这比目击者的描述要年轻得多，目击者一致报告说，最后一次与孩子们在一起的男子是30多岁或40岁出头的中年人。博蒙特儿童也不符合冯·艾内姆首选受害者的特征，他的受害者通常是十几岁到20岁出头的男性。贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆否认参与了博蒙特儿童或乔伊·拉特克利夫和基尔斯滕·戈登的绑架。然而，当后来有报道流传开来，称档案新闻画面背景中捕捉到一个长相酷似年轻冯·艾内姆的男性旁观者，看着警察潜水员搜寻帕达瓦隆加船坞时，有关他参与博蒙特儿童失踪的猜测再次被点燃。由于众所周知杀手会重返犯罪现场重温他们的幻想或检查警察的进展，人们推测冯·艾内姆表现出了教科书般的犯罪行为。法医面部绘图专家将旁观者的图像与年轻冯·艾内姆的图像进行了比较，得出结论认为两人的面部结构存在显着差异。那个长相酷似冯·艾内姆的人被确定就是如此。一个长相相似的人。尽管如此，贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆并未被排除为博蒙特案的嫌疑人。
Following Mr Bea's allegations, South Australian police turned to their investigations to the Maipongel Reservoir. The location Von Einem told Mr Bea he had dumped the bodies of the three children. On February 2, 1990, police divers from the underwater recovery unit arrived to the Flurio Peninsula, 60km south from Adelaide, to conduct a search of the Maipongel Reservoir. The major undertaking presented multiple challenges, as the reservoir held 28,800mg of water, with a depth of 100m in some places, making it difficult for divers to reach the bottom before decompression stops were needed. The water also contained fine silt that significantly reduced visibility, and tons of accumulated silt would have gathered over the years since the children went missing, effectively burying any remains. Police revealed they were searching for bodies, but refused to comment on whether it was those of the missing Beaumont children. Days of searching failed to uncover any remains, and the search was eventually called off. A month later, police confirmed suspicions that they had indeed been searching for the remains of the Beaumont children, as well as those of Kirsty Gordon and Joanne Ratcliffe.
在Be先生的指控之后，南澳大利亚警方将调查转向了迈庞格尔水库。冯·艾内姆告诉Be先生他抛弃这三个孩子尸体的地方。1990年2月2日，来自水下打捞部队的南澳大利亚警察潜水员抵达了距离阿德莱德以南60公里的弗勒里尤半岛，对迈庞格尔水库进行搜查。这项重大行动带来了多重挑战，因为该水库拥有28,800毫克的水量，某些地方的深度达到100米，这使得潜水员在需要进行减压停留之前很难到达底部。水中还含有极大地降低能见的细淤泥，自儿童失踪以来多年积聚的数吨淤泥将有效地掩埋任何遗骸。警方透露他们正在寻找尸体，但拒绝透露这是否是失踪的博蒙特儿童的尸体。数天的搜查未能发现任何遗骸，搜查最终被取消。一个月后，警方证实了他们的怀疑，即他们确实在寻找博蒙特儿童以及基尔斯滕·戈登和乔安妮·拉特克利夫的遗骸。
But nothing had been found. Another massive and devastating setback to the Beaumont case occurred in 1992. Advances in fingerprint technology presented the opportunity to test the fingerprints found on the handwritten letters supposedly penned by Jane Beaumont and her captor back in 1968. The letters that prompted Jim and Nancy Beaumont to travel to Dandenong in Victoria, with the false hopes of being reunited with their children. Testing of the fingerprints revealed the author of the letters to be a 41-year-old man from Victoria. When confronted by police, the Victorian man admitted he had originally written the letters as a teenage prank, which had quickly spiralled out of hand. He had since expressed great remorse for his immature behaviour, regretting the hoax in his adult years. Police determined the man had absolutely no involvement in the Beaumont children's disappearance, and he was promptly eliminated as a suspect.
但什么也没找到。博蒙特案在1992年遭受了另一次巨大且毁灭性的挫折。指纹技术的进步提供了测试1968年据信由简·博蒙特及其绑架者手写的信件上发现的指纹的机会。正是这些信件促使吉姆和南希·博蒙特前往维多利亚州的丹德农，怀着与孩子们团聚的虚假希望。对指纹的测试显示，信件的作者是来自维多利亚州的一名41岁男子。当面对警察的质问时，这名维多利亚男子承认他最初写这些信是作为一个十几岁的恶作剧，结果迅速失控。此后，他对他不成熟的行为表示极大的懊悔，并在成年后对这个恶作剧感到遗憾。警方确定该男子绝对没有参与博蒙特儿童的失踪，并迅速将其排除为嫌疑人。
Given the amount of time that had lapsed and his age at the time of the con, no charges were ever filed against him. As the 1990s came to an end, another person of interest was named in the Beaumont case, Arthur Stanley Brown. In 1998, Brown was charged with the 1970 murders of sisters Judith and Susan McKay, aged 5 and 7, in his hometown of Townsville, Queensland. Brown managed to avoid detection for the murders for almost 30 years. After his eventual arrest, Arthur Brown's photograph was widely circulated in newspapers and television reports nationwide, jogging the memory of a witness to the 1973 abduction of Joanne Ratcliffe and Kirsty Gordon, who identified Brown as the girl's abductor. Even in his older years, Brown bore haunting similarities to the identikit sketches and witness descriptions of the suspect, right down to the white-brimmed Acuba-style hat and horn-rimmed glasses he often wore. Although Brown was settled in Queensland, he had frequently travelled into state for work, and it was possible he had passed through South Australia over the years. As the sketch of Joanne and Kirsty's abductor has been widely compared to that of the man last seen with the Beaumont children, Brown was considered a suspect for both crimes.
鉴于已经过去的时间以及他在恶作剧时的年龄，从未对他提出任何指控。随着20世纪90年代接近尾声，博蒙特案中出现了另一位受关注的人，亚瑟·斯坦利·布朗。1998年，布朗被指控在家乡昆士兰州汤斯维尔谋杀了5岁和7岁的姐妹朱迪思和苏珊·麦凯，时间是1970年。布朗设法逃避了近30年的谋杀罪行侦查。在他最终被捕后，亚瑟·布朗的照片在全国的报纸和电视报道中广泛流传，唤醒了一位1973年乔安妮·拉特克利夫和基尔斯滕·戈登绑架案目击者的记忆，该目击者认出布朗就是女孩的绑架者。即使在晚年，布朗的面容与嫌疑人的身份拼图素描和目击者描述有着惊人的相似之处，甚至包括他经常佩戴的白色帽檐阿库布拉式帽子和黑框眼镜。尽管布朗定居在昆士兰州，但他经常出差外地工作，多年来他有可能路过了南澳大利亚州。由于乔安妮和基尔斯滕绑架者的素描与最后一次被看到与博蒙特儿童在一起的男子的素描进行了广泛的比较，布朗被视为两起犯罪的嫌疑人。
By the time he was arrested for the McKay sisters murders, 86-year-old Arthur Brown was suffering from Alzheimer's disease and dementia and determined unfit for trial. He was therefore released to live out the remainder of his life in a nursing home without ever facing trial for the 45 charges which had arisen since his arrest, including rape, murder, sodomy and deprivation of liberty. He died in 2004, legally as an innocent man. In May 2004, convicted child killer Derek Ernest Percy was named as yet another potential suspect in the Beaumont case. Percy was convicted in 1969 for the abduction and murder of 12-year-old Yvonne Thuy from a beach in Victoria. He was found not guilty due to reasons of insanity, but was held in custody indefinitely. Police suspected Percy could have been involved in up to 9 unsolved crimes related to missing or murdered children throughout Australia during the 60s. This included the unsolved Wanda Beach murders, covered further in episode 1 of Case File.
在他因麦凯姐妹谋杀案被捕时，86岁的亚瑟·布朗患有阿兹海默症和痴呆症，被认定不适合受审。因此，他被释放到疗养院度过余生，从未就逮捕以来产生的45项指控（包括强奸、谋杀、鸡奸和剥夺自由）接受审判。他在2004年去世，在法律上是一个无辜的人。2004年5月，被定罪的儿童杀手德里克·欧内斯特·珀西被点名为博蒙特案的又一个潜在嫌疑人。珀西于1969年因在维多利亚州的海滩绑架和谋杀12岁的阮垂伊芳而被定罪。他因精神失常而被判无罪，但被无限期拘留。警方怀疑珀西可能参与了20世纪60年代整个澳大利亚发生的多达9起与失踪或被谋杀儿童有关的未破案件。这包括未破的旺达海滩谋杀案，这将在《案件档案》第1集中作进一步探讨。
A collection of personal diaries and drawings written and illustrated by Derek Percy detailed disturbing torture fantasies that bore striking similarities to real crimes committed against children that had occurred prior to his arrest. Strengthening the suspicion, he was far more prolific. When questioned about his involvement in other unsolved crimes, Percy told police he believed he was in Adelaide at the time the Beaumont children went missing, but insisted he had no memory of anything else. Even if Percy's memory was correct, he was just 17 years old in 1966, much too young to be the man witnessed in the company of the Beaumont children. Police have also been unable to determine whether Percy had access to a car at the time of the children's disappearance, which investigators presumed would have been necessary to facilitate a quick getaway. The reliability of Percy's claims was one of contention, given the fact he had been deemed legally insane. In July 2013, Derek Percy died without providing any deathbed confessions that many were hoping for, leaving members of law enforcement and many grieving families, including the Beaumonts, without answers. At the turn of the new millennium, the truth of what happened to the Beaumont children remained unknown, but the list of suspects potentially involved in their disappearance continued to grow.
德里克·珀西编写和插图的一系列个人日记和图画详细描述了令人不安的酷刑幻想，与在他被捕之前发生的针对儿童的真实犯罪有着惊人的相似之处。加强怀疑的是，他更加多产。当被问及他参与其他未破案件时，珀西告诉警察，他相信博蒙特儿童失踪时他在阿德莱德，但坚持说他不记得其他任何事情。即使珀西的记忆是正确的，他在1966年也只有17岁，太年轻了，不可能是被目击到陪伴博蒙特儿童的那个男子。警方也无法确定珀西在儿童失踪时是否能使用汽车，调查人员认为这对于协助快速逃跑是必要的。鉴于他被法律判定为精神失常的事实，珀西说辞的可靠性一直存在争议。2013年7月，德里克·珀西去世，没有留下许多人所希望的临终忏悔，这让执法人员和许多悲伤的家庭（包括博蒙特家族）没有得到答案。在新千年来临之际，博蒙特儿童遭遇什么的真相仍然未知，但可能参与他们失踪的嫌疑人名单继续增加。
In the 2000s, convicted child killer James Ryan O'Neill became the subject of the ABC documentary titled The Fisherman Journey into the Mind of a Killer. O'Neill was charged in 1971 for the abduction and sexual assault of four young boys in Victoria, but skipped bail, fled the state, and changed his name. Four years later, in 1975, he was located in Tasmania, where he was arrested and later convicted for the abduction and murder of nine-year-old Tasmanian boy, Ricky Smith. During production of the documentary, O'Neill developed a friendly rapport with his interviewer, former Victorian police detective Gordon Davy. After spending three years getting to know the convicted killer for his documentary, Davy suspected O'Neill could have been involved in several other missing children cases, including the Beaumont children. O'Neill denied having ever visited Adelaide, but his work in the opal industry put him in the South Australian mining town of Coopapede up to 15 times throughout the late 60s and early 70s. A trip that facilitated a stopover in Adelaide to return to his hometown in Melbourne. As Davy interviewed O'Neill's former acquaintances, the retired detective learned from multiple sources that O'Neill had boasted about being responsible for the death of the three Beaumont children.
在20世纪20年代（注：原文2000s），被定罪的儿童杀手詹姆斯·瑞安·奥尼尔成为ABC纪录片《渔夫：进入杀手心灵的旅程》的主题。奥尼尔于1971年因在维多利亚州绑架和性侵四名小男孩而被起诉，但跳保逃匿，逃离该州并改了名字。四年后的1975年，他在塔斯马尼亚被找到，在那里被捕并随后因绑架和谋杀9岁塔斯马尼亚男孩里奇·史密斯而被定罪。在纪录片制作期间，奥尼尔与他的采访者、前维多利亚州警察侦探戈登·戴维建立了友好的关系。在花了两三年时间为了纪录片了解这位被定罪的杀手后，戴维怀疑奥尼尔可能参与了其他几起失踪儿童案件，包括博蒙特儿童案。奥尼尔否认去过阿德莱德，但他在蛋白石行业的工作使他在20世纪60年代末到70年代初多达15次前往南澳大利亚的矿业城镇库帕佩德。这一行程促成了在阿德莱德的中转，以便返回他的家乡墨尔本。当戴维采访奥尼尔的前熟人时，这位退休侦探从多个消息来源得知，奥尼尔曾吹嘘自己对这三个博蒙特儿童的死负责。
Davy suspected O'Neill could have taken the children all the way to Coopapede, 846 kilometres north of Adelaide, where he then dumped their bodies down an abandoned mine shaft. Davy took his information to South Australian police, who subsequently interviewed O'Neill, but ultimately ruled him out as a suspect. Yet another two suspects in the Beaumont case were uncovered when allegations made by the adult children of Adelaide businessman Alan Maxwell McIntyre were heavily publicised in 2007. McIntyre's children, who had publicly accused their father of being an incestuous pedophile, claimed that he, along with business colleague and former scoutmaster Anthony Munro, went to Glenelbeach on Australia Day in 1966. When the two men returned home, they were both visibly agitated. McIntyre's children claimed sand and blood were visible in Munro's car and professed to seeing the bodies of three children in the boot of the vehicle. Police investigated these shocking claims, but ultimately cleared Alan Maxwell McIntyre and Anthony Munro of any involvement in the Beaumont children's disappearance. Yet McIntyre himself later admitted that there was partial truth to the allegations. During an exclusive interview with Adelaide newspaper The Advertiser, McIntyre vindicated himself and pinned the entire crime on his friend Anthony Munro, alleging that on Australia Day 1966, Munro arrived at his property with three bodies in the back of his car.
戴维怀疑奥尼尔可能把孩子们一直带到了库帕佩德，距离阿德莱德以北846公里，然后把他们的尸体扔进了一个废弃的矿井里。戴维将他的信息带给了南澳大利亚警方，后者随后讯问了奥尼尔，但最终将他排除了嫌疑。当阿德莱德商人阿兰·麦克斯韦·麦金太尔的成年子女在2007年大肆宣传他们的指控时，博蒙特案的另外两名嫌疑人浮出水面。麦金太尔的孩子们公开指责他们的父亲是一个乱伦的恋童癖者，他们声称他和商业同事兼前童军领袖安东尼·芒罗在1966年的澳大利亚日去了格雷内尔奇海滩。当这两个男人回家时，他们都明显感到心神不宁。麦金太尔的孩子们声称在芒罗的汽车里可以看到沙子和血液，并宣称看到车辆后备箱里有三个孩子的尸体。警方调查了这些令人震惊的指控，但最终洗清了阿兰·麦克斯韦·麦金太尔和安东尼·芒罗与博蒙特儿童失踪案的任何牵连。然而麦金太尔本人后来承认这些指控有部分是真实的。在接受阿德莱德报纸《广告商报》的独家采访时，麦金太尔为自己辩白，并将整起罪行归咎于他的朋友安东尼·芒罗，声称在1966年的澳大利亚日，芒罗带着三具尸体出现在他的地产上，尸体放在他汽车后座。
McIntyre described Munro as, quote, one of the most evil pieces of work that ever drew breath. McIntyre continued to deny any personal involvement with the crime up until his death in 2017. That same year, 2017, 72-year-old Anthony Munro pled a guilty to 10 unrelated child sex crimes dating back to the 60s, some of which occurred in Glenelbeach during the time period the Beaumont children went missing. Munro was sentenced to 10 years in prison with a non-parole period of five years and five months, and will be eligible for parole in 2022. At the time of the Beaumont children's disappearance, Alan Maxwell McIntyre owned a block of land in the York Peninsula town of Stansbury, 200km west of Adelaide. His children alleged that a sinkhole on this property was filled in just weeks after the Beaumont children disappeared, but police refused to excavate the land due to lack of evidence. In 2006, to commemorate the 40th anniversary of the Beaumont children's disappearance, true crime author Alan Whitaker released an in-depth book exploring the case, titled, Searching for the Beaumont Children. Several months after its release, Whitaker received a phone call from a woman named Angela, alleging her former father-in-law was responsible for the abduction and murder of Jane, Anna, and Grant Beaumont.
麦金太尔将芒罗描述为，引用原话，“有史以来最邪恶的恶魔之一”。麦金太尔直到2017年去世前一直否认自己与这起罪行有任何个人牵连。同年，即2017年，72岁的安东尼·芒罗对追溯到20世纪60年代的10项无关的儿童性犯罪表示认罪，其中一些发生在博蒙特儿童失踪期间的格雷内尔奇海滩。芒罗被判处10年监禁，不得假释期为五年零五个月，并将在2022年有资格获得假释。在博蒙特儿童失踪时，阿兰·麦克斯韦·麦金太尔在距离阿德莱德以西200公里的约克半岛小镇斯坦斯伯里拥有一块土地。他的孩子声称这块土地上的一个天坑在博蒙特儿童失踪几周后就被填平了，但由于缺乏证据，警方拒绝挖掘这块土地。2006年，为了纪念博蒙特儿童失踪40周年，真实犯罪作家阿兰·韦蒂克出版了一本深入探讨该案的书，名为《寻找博蒙特儿童》。出版几个月后，韦蒂克接到了一位名叫安吉拉的女性的电话，她声称她的前岳父是绑架和谋杀简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特的幕后黑手。
Alan Whitaker remained skeptical. Over the decades, the high-profile mystery had attracted elaborate hoaxes, speculation, and theories, with investigators and journalists weeding out countless claims from people who believed they either knew the whereabouts of the Beaumont children, or the identity of the trio's killer. Some of the more outrageous claims included people coming forward claiming to be the grown-up Beaumont children. The nation's desperate need for closure ensured every lead was investigated, but none were substantiated. However, the information provided by Angela to Alan Whitaker was compelling, as it wove authentically with known facts of the case. She alleged her ex-husband Hayden had once confessed that his father had something to do with the Beaumont children's disappearance, adding that the children were, quote, in the pit. Although she was shocked by the comment at the time, Angela was unsure what to make of it. Hayden had only recently confided that his father had subjected him to horrific sexual abuse throughout his childhood, and was in an emotionally fragile state. It wasn't until Angela read Alan Whitaker's book about the Beaumont case that her gut instincts told her Hayden's allegation might be true. In his book, Whitaker explained that on Australia Day 1966, the Beaumont children had paid for their lunch at Wenzel's cake shop using a mysteriously lavish one-pound note.
阿兰·韦蒂克仍然持怀疑态度。几十年来，这个高调的谜团吸引了精心策划的恶作剧、猜测和理论，调查人员和记者排除了无数声称自己知道博蒙特儿童下落或三人凶手身份的各方说法。一些比较离谱的说法包括有人站出来声称自己是长大了的博蒙特儿童。全国对真相大白的迫切需求确保了每一条线索都得到了调查，但没有一条得到证实。然而，安吉拉提供给阿兰·韦蒂克的信息令人信服，因为它与该案的已知事实完美地交织在一起。她声称她的前夫海顿曾坦白说他的父亲与博蒙特儿童的失踪有关，并补充说这些孩子们，引用原话，“在那个坑里”。虽然她当时对这一评论感到震惊，但安吉拉不确定该作何感想。海顿直到最近才向她吐露，他的父亲在整个童年时期对他进行了可怕的性虐待，并且处于情感脆弱的状态。直到安吉拉读了阿兰·韦蒂克关于博蒙特案的书后，她的直觉告诉她海顿的指控可能是真的。在他的书中，韦蒂克解释说，在1966年的澳大利亚日，博蒙特儿童用一张神秘而奢华的一英镑纸币支付了他们在文策尔蛋糕店的午餐。
This was one of the case's most significant clues, as it was suspected the money was given to the siblings by someone involved in their disappearance. According to Angela, her wealthy former father-in-law was notorious for handing out one-pound notes to his son and his friends to entice them to go out and play, so he could be left alone. Immediately intrigued, Alan Whitaker informed his research partner Stuart Mullins about Angela's phone call, and Mullins dove head-first into investigating the allegations. The suspect in question was Harry Phipps, a millionaire businessman who was regarded as charming and charismatic. In 1966, Phipps lived in Glenelg with his wife and teenage son, and owned and operated the Custoloy factory in North Plimpton, located four kilometres north of his home. The Phipps house was located on the corner of Augusta and Sussex streets, a mere 300 metres away from both Wenzel's cake shop and the chain shed in Collie Reserve, where the Beaumont children were last sited. This provided a perfect triangle between the investigation's two key locations and the suspect's property. In fact, the lawns of Collie Reserve could be seen from the suspect's home, and was less than a minute walk away down Augusta Street, a residential road lined with character homes and pine trees.
这是该案最重要的线索之一，因为怀疑这笔钱是参与他们失踪的人给这几个兄弟姐妹的。据安吉拉说，她富有的前岳父因向他的儿子和他的朋友们发放一英镑纸币而臭名昭著，以引诱他们出去玩，这样他就可以一个人呆着。阿兰·韦蒂克立即产生了兴趣，将安吉拉的电话告知了他的研究伙伴斯图尔特·穆林斯，穆林斯一头扎进对这些指控的调查中。有问题的嫌疑人是哈里·菲普斯，一个被认为迷人且富有个人魅力的百万富翁商人。1966年，菲普斯和他的妻子以及十几岁的儿子住在格雷内尔，在距离他家四公里以北的诺斯普林普顿拥有并经营卡斯特洛伊工厂。菲普斯的房子位于奥古斯塔街和萨塞克斯街的拐角处，距离文策尔蛋糕店和科利保护区内的链条棚（博蒙特儿童最后被目击的地方）仅30米（注：原文300米）。这为调查的两个关键地点和嫌疑人的财产提供了一个完美的三角形。事实上，从嫌疑人的家中可以看到科利保护区的草坪，沿着奥古斯塔街步行不到一分钟即可到达，这是一条两旁种有特色房屋和松树的住宅路。
Additionally, Harry Phipps was aged in his early 40s in 1966, and his appearance bore striking resemblance to the sketch of the man last seen playing with Jane, Anna and Grant. He was approximately six feet tall, with an athletic build, long face, high forehead, and wavy, light brown to blonde hair parted to the side. As Angela's claims continued to gain merit, the investigation was handed over to Private Detective Bill Hayes, a former detective for the South Australian Police. By the time Angela had implicated her former father-in-law in the Beaumont children's disappearance, Harry Phipps had been deceased for two years, having succumbed to Alzheimer's in 2004. Nevertheless, researcher Stuart Mullins proceeded to look into the life of the prominent, respected businessman, to determine whether the accusations against him could be true. Mullins arrived to Glenelg, visiting the house behind Collie Reserve where Harry Phipps lived until his death. The house now belonged to Phipps' second wife. During a tour of the house, Mullins was taken into an underground cellar which Phipps had used as his workshop. There, Mullins caught sight of something sitting on a shelf. It was a white, clip-top vintage purse in pristine condition.
此外，哈里·菲普斯在1966年处于40岁出头，他的外表与最后一次被看到与简、安娜和格兰特一起玩耍的男子的素描有着惊人的相似之处。他身高约六英尺，体格健壮，长脸，高额头，波浪状的浅棕色到金色头发偏向一侧。随着安吉拉的指控继续获得认可，调查被移交给前南澳大利亚警察局侦探比尔·海耶斯私家侦探。当安吉拉将她的前岳父牵连到博蒙特儿童的失踪案中时，哈里·菲普斯已经去世两年了，他于2004年死于阿兹海默症。尽管如此，研究员斯图尔特·穆林斯还是着手调查这位杰出、受人尊敬的商人的生活，以确定对他的指控是否可能是真的。穆林斯抵达格雷内尔，参观了哈里·菲普斯生前居住的科利保护区后面的房子。这栋房子现在属于菲普斯的第二任妻子。在参观房子期间，穆林斯被带到一个地下酒窖，菲普斯曾将其用作他的车间。在那里，穆林斯瞥见架子上放着一样东西。那是一个处于崭新状态的白色夹扣式复古钱包。
The very same kind Jane Beaumont had left home with on January 26, 1966. Unable to take his mind off this bizarre sighting, the next day Mullins returned to the house to question Phipps' widow about the purse. When he mentioned Jane Beaumont had owned that exact type of purse, Phipps' widow became defensive, claiming she had bought it from an op shop the previous week. This claim struck Mullins' odd, given the woman had inherited millions of dollars from her deceased husband's estate and had no need to buy a cheap, second-hand child's purse. Mullins informed police of the discovery, but when a detective visited the house days later to retrieve the purse, Phipps' widow advised she had thrown it away before threatening Mullins with legal action if he returned. In 2008, Harry Phipps' son Hayden agreed to an interview with private investigator Bill Hayes to provide further insight into his allegations that his father had murdered the three Beaumont children. According to Hayden, his father was far from the image of charming, respectable businessman he projected, but instead a predatory pedophile and abusive alcoholic with a love for guns. Hayden recalled a chilling memory from over 40 years prior occurring on January 26, 1966.
这正是简·博蒙特于1966年1月26日离开家时带的那种钱包。脑海中挥之不去这个奇怪的目击事件，第二天穆林斯回到房子里询问菲普斯的遗孀关于钱包的事。当他提到简·博蒙特拥有那种确切类型的钱包时，菲普斯的遗孀变得具有防御性，声称她是前一周从一家慈善商店买的。这种说法让穆林斯觉得很奇怪，鉴于这个女人从她死去的丈夫的遗产中继承了数百万美元，根本没有必要买一个便宜的、二手的儿童钱包。穆林斯将这一发现告知了警方，但几天后当一名侦探访问该房子取回钱包时，菲普斯的遗孀建议她在丢弃钱包之前威胁穆林斯如果他回来将采取法律行动。2008年，哈里·菲普斯的儿子海顿同意接受私家侦探比尔·海耶斯的采访，以进一步深入了解他关于他父亲谋杀三个博蒙特儿童的指控。据海顿说，他的父亲远非他所投射的迷人、受人尊敬的商人的形象，而是一个掠夺性的恋童癖者和喜欢枪支的虐待狂酗酒者。海顿回忆起40多年前发生在1966年1月26日的一个令人不寒栗的记忆。
On that summer's day, teenage Hayden was smoking cigarettes in a cubby house in the backyard of his family's Glenelg home when he caught sight of his father walking into the house with three young children in tow. They each had short, cropped hair, the oldest one was carrying a shoulder bag, and all appeared to be lost. The three children went inside the Phipps' home, but never emerged. Hayden later saw his father load four large bags into the boot of his car and drive away. When Hayden entered the house, the children were nowhere to be seen. Alan Whitaker and Stuart Mullins presented their research into Harry Phipps in a 2013 novel titled The Satin Man, uncovering the mystery of the missing Beaumont children. The title was inspired by Phipps' insatiable sexual fetish for the silky fabric. Rather than naming Harry Phipps outright, pseudonyms were used to protect the identities of the accused and his family.
在那个夏日，十几岁的海顿在格雷内尔家族住宅后院的一个简易小屋里抽烟，当时他瞥见他的父亲带着三个年幼的孩子走进了房子。他们每个人都留着短短的剪发，最大的一个提着一个单肩包，看起来都迷路了。这三个孩子走进了菲普斯的家，但再也没有出来。海顿后来看到他的父亲把四个大袋子装进他汽车的后备箱并开车离开。当海顿进入房子时，孩子们无影无踪。阿兰·韦蒂克和斯图尔特·穆林斯在2013年出版的一本名为《缎面人》的小说中展示了他们对哈里·菲普斯的研究，揭开了失踪博蒙特儿童的谜团。这个书名灵感来自于菲普斯对丝绸面料的无法满足的性癖好。书中没有直接点名哈里·菲普斯，而是使用了化名来保护被告及其家人的身份。
In the book, Harry Phipps was referred to as Hank Harrison. Following the release of The Satin Man, media interest in the new Beaumont case suspect Hank Harrison was high. When Channel 7 current affairs show Today Tonight aired the story, they canned the pseudonyms in exchange for use of the real names. Harry Phipps was exposed. But Today Tonight revealing Phipps' former business as the Castelloy factory in North Plimpton, it sparked the memory of two brothers who came forward asserting they had been hired by Harry Phipps to dig a hole at the factory site in 1966. Just three days after the Beaumont children went missing. The brothers, now aged in their 60s, were teenagers who lived locally at the time and often picked up odd jobs to earn extra cash.
在这本书中，哈里·菲普斯被称为汉克·哈里森。随着《缎面人》的出版，媒体对新博蒙特案嫌疑人汉克·哈里森的兴趣很高。当7频道时事节目《今晚今晨》播出这个故事时，他们取消了化名，换成了真名。哈里·菲普斯暴露了。但《今晚今晨》揭露菲普斯以前的业务是诺斯普林普顿的卡斯特洛伊工厂，这唤醒了两兄弟的记忆，他们站出来断言他们在1966年被哈里·菲普斯雇佣在工厂旧址挖一个洞。就在博蒙特儿童失踪三天后。这两兄弟现在已经60多岁了，当时是当地的青少年，经常接一些零工来赚取额外的现金。
Phipps instructed them to dig a hole with the dimensions of one metre wide, two metres long and two metres deep. It was a searing hot weekend and the factory was closed as Phipps watched the brothers closely, urging them to dig deeper. Two days later, they were paid handsomely for their work, with Phipps handing them both one pound notes. When the brothers heard the Castelloy factory mentioned on Today Tonight, they were hit with the haunting realisation they could have unknowingly dug a grave for the three Beaumont children. Their story also corroborated allegations Harry Phipps' son Hayden had made to private investigator Bill Hayes, who said his father had buried the children at the industrial site. Hayden told Hayes, quote, they are in the sand pit, Bill. Although police maintained there was no evidence to substantiate allegations made against Harry Phipps in relation to the Beaumont children's disappearance, they agreed to conduct a search of the Castelloy factory site. The factory had changed significantly since 1966 and the brothers were unable to pinpoint the exact location where they had originally dug the hole, but one brother believed he had a general idea.
菲普斯指示他们挖一个宽一米、长两米、深两米的洞。这是一个酷热的周末，工厂关门了，菲普斯紧紧盯着兄弟俩，敦促他们挖得更深。两天后，他们因工作得到了丰厚的报酬，菲普斯递给他们两人一英镑纸币。当这两兄弟听到《今晚今晨》中提到卡斯特洛伊工厂时，他们痛苦地意识到他们可能在不知情的情况下为这三个博蒙特儿童挖了一个坟墓。他们的故事也证实了哈里·菲普斯的儿子海顿向私家侦探比尔·海耶斯提出的指控，海顿曾说他的父亲将孩子们埋在了工业基地。海顿告诉海耶斯，引用原话，“他们在沙坑里，比尔”。尽管警方坚持认为没有证据证实针对哈里·菲普斯与博蒙特儿童失踪相关的指控，但他们同意对卡斯特洛伊工厂旧址进行搜查。自1966年以来，工厂发生了巨大变化，兄弟俩无法准确指出他们最初挖洞确切位置，但其中一个兄弟相信他有一个大致的想法。
In October 2014, South Australian police used ground penetrating radar to locate a small anomaly in the sighted area, but upon excavation of the one metre square segment of Earth, nothing was found. This excavation effort was widely criticised as neither brother was on site during the dig and critics believed the police didn't dig deep enough or in the correct spot. Investigator Bill Hayes said, quote, it wasn't anyone's fault, it was the geography that had changed. When we saw the aerial photos, we knew we'd dug in the wrong place. In January 2018, South Australian police launched a highly publicised joint investigation with Channel 7 and Flinders University to conduct a more thorough excavation of the Castelloy factory. With further assistance from the brothers, forensic scientists uncovered an area of disturbed Earth, approximately the size of a grave. It had been 52 years since 9-year-old Jane, 7-year-old Anna and 4-year-old Grant had mysteriously vanished and expectations across Australia were high, hoping this second, more thoroughly planned and orchestrated dig would lead to a major breakthrough. Yet, the excavation revealed nothing more than rubbish and a few animal bones. Major crime detective, Superintendent Desbray said, quote,
2014年10月，南澳大利亚警方使用探地雷达在标记区域定位了一个小异常，但在挖掘了一米见方的地球片段后，什么也没找到。这一挖掘努力受到广泛批评，因为两兄弟在挖掘期间都不在现场，批评者认为警方挖掘得不够深或不在正确的位置。侦探比尔·海耶斯说，引用原话，“这不是任何人的错，是地理环境发生了变化。当我们看到航拍照片时，我们知道我们挖错了地方。”2018年1月，南澳大利亚警方与7频道和弗林德斯大学联合发起了一项备受瞩目的联合调查，对卡斯特洛伊工厂进行了更彻底的挖掘。在兄弟俩的进一步协助下，法医科学家发现了一片受干扰的土地，大约有一个坟墓的大小。距离9岁的简、7岁的安娜和4岁的格兰特神秘失踪已经过去了52年，全澳大利亚的期望很高，希望第二次经过更彻底规划和策划的挖掘能够带来重大突破。然而，挖掘结果除了垃圾和一些动物骨骼外，什么也没有发现。重案侦探德斯布雷警司说，引用原话：
We are confident there has been a hole or holes dug here historically and those holes have been used for at least a period of time as some sort of tip. There's nothing at all that's been located today that's in any way connected to the Beaumont children. Sadly, this means for the Beaumont family, we still have no answers. We will always do everything humanly possible to locate the Beaumont children and return them to their family. As of late 2018, the whereabouts of Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont remains unknown. The investigation into their disappearance is regarded as one of the largest criminal investigations in Australian history and holds the tragic legacy as being one of the country's most infamous unsolved mysteries. To this day, a $1 million reward remains on offer for information that leads to the truth about what happened to the Beaumont children that summer day in 1966. Jim and Nancy Beaumont are both aged in their 90s and still reside in Adelaide.
我们确信历史上这里曾被挖过一个或多个洞，并且这些洞在一段时间内曾被用作某种垃圾倾倒场。今天现场发现的任何东西都与博蒙特孩子们没有任何联系。遗憾的是，这意味着对博蒙特家族而言，我们仍然没有任何答案。我们将永远尽人类最大的努力找到博蒙特的孩子们并将他们送回家人身边。截至2018年底，简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特的下落依然不明。对他们失踪案的调查被视为澳大利亚历史上最大规模的刑事调查之一，并作为该国最著名的未解之谜之一留下了悲剧性的遗产。时至今日，仍有一百万澳元的悬赏金，以征集能够揭示1966年那个夏日博蒙特孩子们究竟发生了什么真相的线索。吉姆和南希·博蒙特都已经90多岁了，目前仍住在阿德莱德。
They have not officially spoken to the media in over 40 years and have come to terms with the likelihood that they may never learn what happened to their three children. Although presumed murdered, if the Beaumont children were still alive today, Jane would be 62 years old, Anna would be 59 and Grant would be 57. The sketch of the unknown man seen playing with the Beaumont children at Coley Reserve remains the only circulating image of the suspected perpetrator. No other criminal case in Australian history has attracted as many suspects, with hundreds of people investigated over the years, including the most notorious and vile criminals from across the country. In February 2018, South Australian Major Crime Detective Superintendent Des Bray set up to a dozen potential persons of interest could not be excluded by police. This list includes Bevan Spencer Von Einem, Arthur Stanley Brown, Derek Ernest Percy, James Ryan O'Neill, Anthony Munro, Alan Maxwell McIntyre and Harry Phipps. In Australia, there are more than 2,000 long-term missing people and over 500 archived sets of unidentified human remains. In June of 2018, Susie Ratcliffe, the younger sister of Joanne Ratcliffe, the 11-year-old girl abducted from Adelaide Oval in 1973, called for all evidence in long-term missing children cases to be urgently retested for DNA.
他们在40多年里没有正式接受过媒体采访，并且已经接受了他们可能永远无法得知三个孩子遭遇了什么的可能性。虽然被推定遇害，如果博蒙特的孩子们今天仍然活着，简将是62岁，安娜59岁，格兰特57岁。那个被看到在科利保护区与博蒙特孩子们一起玩耍的身份不明男子的速写，依然是目前唯一流传的嫌疑人画像。澳大利亚历史上的任何其他刑事案件都没有吸引过这么多的嫌疑人，多年来有数百人受到调查，其中包括来自全国各地最声名狼藉、最穷凶极恶的罪犯。2018年2月，南澳大利亚重案组侦探警司德斯·布雷列出了多达十多名警方无法排除的潜在利益相关人员。这份名单包括贝文·斯潘塞·冯·艾内姆、亚瑟·斯坦利·布朗、德里克·欧内斯特·珀西、詹姆斯·瑞安·奥尼尔、安东尼·芒罗、阿兰·麦克斯韦·麦金太尔和哈里·菲普斯。在澳大利亚，有超过2000名长期失踪人口和500多组未确认身份的人类遗骸档案。2018年6月，1973年在阿德莱德椭圆球场被绑架的11岁女孩乔安娜·拉特克利夫的妹妹苏茜·拉特克利夫呼吁，对所有长期失踪儿童案件中的证据进行紧急重新进行DNA检测。
Like the Beaumont children, Joanne Ratcliffe and Kirsty Gordon have never been found and their abductor never identified. Susie Ratcliffe believes the remains of her sister could be amongst the unidentified remains, along with those of Kirsty Gordon and the Beaumont children. Susie is supported by renowned forensic scientist Dr Jody Ward, who wants Australia to commit to a laboratory dedicated solely to missing persons casework. According to Dr Ward, the current capabilities in DNA forensics could allow experts to match remains with some of Australia's long-term missing persons cases and potentially provide relief to suffering families. The unexplained disappearance of the Beaumont children on Australia Day in 1966 irreparably shattered Jim and Nancy Beaumont, who for years lived in the hopes that Jane, Anna and Grant would one day walk through the gates of the family home. Their loss was felt by the whole nation, creating a legacy of paranoia and fear that remains to this day. The Beaumont story has been a cautionary tale for generations, providing a stark awakening to the evils that lie in the underbelly of our society. January 26, 1966 has been coined as the day Australia lost its innocence, with the disappearance of the Beaumont children paving the way for a greater awareness of stranger danger.
就像博蒙特的孩子们一样，乔安娜·拉特克利夫和柯蒂斯·戈登从未被找到，她们的绑架者也从未被确定。苏茜·拉特克利夫相信，她姐姐的遗骸可能就在那些未确认身份的遗骸之中，其中也可能包括柯蒂斯·戈登和博蒙特的孩子们的遗骸。苏茜得到了著名法医科学家乔迪·沃德博士的支持，后者希望澳大利亚建立一个专门致力于失踪人员案件的实验室。根据沃德博士的说法，当前DNA法医的技术能力可以使专家将遗骸与澳大利亚的一些长期失踪人口案件进行比对，并可能为痛苦中的家庭带来慰藉。1966年澳大利亚日博蒙特孩子们无法解释的失踪，无可挽回地粉碎了吉姆和南希·博蒙特，他们多年来一直生活在简、安娜和格兰特终有一天会走回家族宅邸大门的希望中。他们的失落被整个国家所感受到，并留下了一种至今仍然存在的偏执和恐惧遗产。博蒙特的故事一直是几代人的警世故事，让人们对我们社会阴暗面中存在的邪恶有了严酷的觉醒。1966年1月26日被创造为澳大利亚失去天真的日子，博蒙特孩子们的失踪为人们对陌生人危险的更高警惕铺平了道路。
The names Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont have become etched into Australian history, and their legacy will never be forgotten. The investigation remains open. A large collection of candid photographs exhibits the short, though carefree lives of Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont. Taken by their parents during holidays and special moments, the black and white images perfectly capture the essence of the Beaumont family's idyllic life. The photos show the children all smiles as they go about their daily lives. Grant grinning on his tricycle, Jane and Anna side by side riding the elephant cart at the Adelaide Zoo, and a Jane carrying her baby brother in a wooden laundry basket. In one photograph, the three inseparable siblings stand together excitedly, showing off their loot from the 1965 Royal Adelaide Show. For Jim Beaumont, these photographs, along with letters written by his eldest daughter Jane, embody the memory of the family he lost.
简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特的名字已经铭刻在澳大利亚的历史中，他们的传奇将永远不会被遗忘。调查仍在继续。大量坦诚的照片展现了简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特短暂却无忧无虑的生活。这些黑白照片由他们的父母在假期和特殊时刻拍摄，完美地捕捉了博蒙特家族田园诗般生活的精髓。照片显示孩子们在日常生活中满脸笑容。格兰特在三轮车上咧嘴笑，简和安娜并肩骑着阿德莱德动物园的大象车，简用木制洗衣篮抱着她的小弟弟。在一张照片中，三个形影不离的兄妹兴奋地站在一起，炫耀他们从1965年皇家阿德莱德展会上得到的战利品。对吉姆·博蒙特来说，这些照片以及他的大女儿简写的信，凝聚了他对失去的家庭的记忆。
The last letter Jane ever wrote to her parents would serve as a constant reminder of the kind, caring and protective nature of the young girl, who would always go to great lengths to shield her younger siblings from harm. Just days before Australia Day 1966, Jane was proudly babysitting her younger siblings while her parents enjoyed a night out with friends. Before she retired the bed for the night, Jane wrote her parents a note to fill them in on the events of the evening. Dear mum and dad, I am just about to go to bed and the time is 9. I have put Grant's nape on so there is no need to worry about him wetting on the sheet. Grant wanted to sleep in his own bed, so one of you will have to sleep with Anna. Although you will not find the rooms in very good condition, I hope you will find them as comfortable as we do. Good night to you both. Jane.
简写给父母的最后一封信成为了这个善良、富有同情心和保护欲的小女孩的恒久提醒，她总是竭尽全力保护她的弟弟妹妹免受伤害。就在1966年澳大利亚日的前几天，简自豪地照顾着年幼的弟弟妹妹，而她的父母则与朋友共度夜晚。在入睡前，简给父母写了一张便条，向他们汇报当晚的情况。亲爱的爸爸妈妈，我正准备上床睡觉，时间是9点。我给格兰特换上了尿布，所以不用担心他会尿床。格兰特想睡在他自己的床上，所以你们其中一人必须和安娜睡。虽然你们可能会发现房间的状况不太好，但我希望你们会发现它们和我们一样舒适。祝你们晚安。简。
P.S. I hope you had a very nice time. Wherever you went. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
附言：我希望你们过得很愉快。无论你们去了哪里。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。